we have new reports at the fbi has
seized the cell phone of a republican
representative a day after the fbi
raided the home of donald trump this
could be
i mean well you know what i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say what it could be i'm
gonna say this george conway of all
people said they have crossed the
rubicon i completely agree
it we woke up uh when we got that news
we covered it that was the moment this
country was forever changed and now we
are in what donald trump calls dark days
we now have new information which is
lighting up the internet with conspiracy
theories the judge who reportedly signed
the search warrant of trump's home
is linked to jeffrey epstein in and when
i first heard this i was like linked to
what does that mean like he knew a guy
who knew a guy and then it's like
actually he was a federal prosecutor who
switched sides and started working to
defend epstein's lieutenants and it's
like oh
what
that's the guy he's an obama donor as
well
okay well the other thing is when
stories like this big happen that's all
the news is
so we're gonna talk about that plus we
got other weird stories like okay i'm
just gonna say some dude was sending
feces to republicans in the mail
what and hillary clinton is fundraising
off of trump being raided basically
saying
that what she did was worse but she got
away with it so give her money because
she knows you will
before we get started my friends head
over to surfinginternetsafe.com
to get your virtual shield virtual
private network that keeps you safe as
you browse the web it's a basic layer of
security so that if you know a
corporation is trying to steal your data
or maybe it's a robot from that
corporation just tracking your data or a
regular old hacker or just nefarious
actors it makes it a lot harder for them
to do head over to surfing surfing
internet safe they got a 50 life 50 off
lifetime discount they say their vpn
service
is compatible with all devices and
allows you to browse the web safely
securely securely and anonymously using
their global network of servers and
private ips virtual shield lets you
browse the web completely anonymously so
big name internet service providers and
other third parties will not be able to
monitor your internet activity and
browsing history that one can be pretty
good when using their vpn service your
traffic is routed through their secure
and encrypted servers that means any
restrictions censorship or blocks on
your internet are bypassed it's
completely free for 30 days it's
available on mac windows iphone ipad
android and chrome it does all the work
for you virtual shield even routes your
internet through i'm sorry it completely
encrypts your wi-fi connection as well
so even in between you and your your uh
modem for instance
they've got personal family and business
plans available family plans include 15
devices and the business plan allows you
to add as many employees as you need if
you're looking for a virtual private
network go to virtual shield at surfing
internet safe support companies that
support shows you like we're eternally
grateful for virtual shield being our
first sponsor still here thank you very
much surfing internetsafe.com don't
forget head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly and get access to our after
hours uncensored show monday through
thursday at 11 pm we're gonna have one
of those shows for you tonight and we
had one with larry elder last night it
was particularly uh it was really good
and uh check out the library of condo we
have dave landau it was a really really
great members only show you'll want to
check that one out and then we've also
got sales from the inter inverted world
so we've got a whole bunch of stuff in
the works we're launching new shows
we've got two documentaries currently
being produced which will be in the
members only section we're going to be
creating a whole bunch of content for
you so we really do appreciate it
without further uh oh so also smash the
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends without
further ado joining us today to talk
about all of this and more is michael
seifert how's it going thanks for having
me it's going well yeah glad to be here
who are you uh uh good corn farmer sir
yes
yes my last name is pronounced seifert
which apparently
in kind of german slang used to mean
exceptional corn harvester so i can
thank my ancestors for the endearing
nickname uh yeah my name is michael
seifert i'm the ceo and founder of a
company called public square that's uh
how most people know me as of late uh we
are essentially the largest network of
non-woke businesses in the country we
have been disheartened by the world of
woke corporatism so we built a platform
that's interactive and social in nature
for people to be able to connect with
the companies that are standing against
corporatism and i will also and on top
of that i'm i'm excited you're here we
recently removed paypal oh it has a
subscription option from timcast.com and
use parallel economy which is censorship
resistant co-founded by dan bongino it's
part of this rumble anti-silicon valley
big tech net network or whatever you
want to call it but uh we we here at
temcas we're putting our money where our
mouth is and i'm excited you're here to
talk about how we can do more how other
people can do more and we can uh
stop giving money to people who hate us
amen it's that simple right on we also
have mary morgan you do have me yes hi
uh my name is mary i co-host pop culture
crisis on youtube we're here at tim cast
and we cover
all the celebrities movies
uh entertainment art culture games stuff
like that we have fun over there i'm
happy to be back and i know you all
missed me very much you also have ian
crossland
video game connoisseur actor musician
my pleasure to be here grace with your
looking forward thank you so much mary
great to see you too uh let's keep it
going that's right i am also on pop
culture crisis every wednesday three to
about 5 p.m it's always a lot of fun you
guys should join us over there let's go
come on just real quick what do you
think we should we should leave with the
epstein thing or the or the raid so so
the raid on the season of the cell phone
i think is like big breaking news yeah
it's like maybe we should go with that
and then we'll talk about the epstein
stuff right
yeah i think that
let's jump with this we'll jump to the
story then we have this from washington
times trump ally rep scott perry says
fbi seized his cell phone
one day after the raid on former
president donald trump the fbi has
seized the cell phone of a republican
member of congress rep scott perry
pennsylvania republican said in a
statement to fox news that three fbi
agents handed him a warrant and demanded
his phone quote
this morning while traveling with my
family three fbi agents visited me and
seized my cell phone they made no
attempt to contact my lawyer who would
have made arrangements for them to have
my phone if that was their wish i'm
outraged though not surprised that under
the fb that under the f that the fbi
under the direction of merrick garland's
doj would seize the phone of a sitting
member of congress mr perry's statement
did not elaborate on whether he was told
anything about what the fbi was seeking
on the phone
mr perry is a founding member and
current chairman of the conservative
house freedom caucus
as a close ally of former president
donald trump the democrat appointed
january 6 panel has shown interest in
his communications with trump around
that time it's fascinating wasn't ron
desantis also one of the founders of the
freedom caucus i'm not sure
i would believe it
we're big fans of the freedom caucus we
are and i have to say this is not
surprising in the least
but uh
man
look
when a story like this happens
it's kind of like oh wow that's bad
when steve bannon gets arrested you're
like oh wow that's bad
after the raid on donald trump's home
it's a it's a whole new territory now
now this is
a sitting member of congress had his
phone seized by the feds
yeah desantis did help start the freedom
caucus where we are right now is that
it's not former administration officials
it is current
elected representatives being targeted
by the department of justice
so where does this end so i remember you
talking about yeah of course he said it
all right take your drinks everyone so
tim talked about this situation where
there would be two cars driving
somewhere i don't remember the story it
was matt tybee matt tybee wrote this
really matt's ieb wrote i think it was
last october that's great
that we will get to the arrest that man
phase
which sparks a civil war where you will
have two cars speeding towards a a
police jurisdiction where the men will
jump out and point at each other arrest
that man is that where we are
we're beyond that we're you know so so
the question about that stuff is
will there be a fight over the
institution of law enforcement
democrats have weaponized it republicans
are too weak look i appreciate rick
santorum being on this show but he was
like no we got to follow the rules we
can't do this stuff it's like i'll see
in the gulag brother
i'm full abolish the fbi at this point
oh yeah yeah i mean it and that's the
reality it's like that i think in the
battle for law enforcement there's still
some constitution adhering awesome local
police officers sheriffs and communities
around the country
but the fbi and i'm not saying that
they're all about apples but my goodness
i mean the whole institution itself has
been robbed and is so centralized in
nature so i i people still have hope for
it i don't i think the only answer with
the fbi an institution that's as
nationalized and centralized as that at
this point is get rid of it we're in
like get reformat a completely different
reality maybe not completely but but
relative to like 1970 when it was
wiretapping phones and it was a big deal
like when nixon got found to be
wiretapping the democratic whatever it
was the democrats during his
campaign or whatever um
now it's digital so much data is stored
digitally and for for these companies to
be what i'm calling the fbi a company
because it's kind of functioning like
its own
company uh is able to just like peruse
digital data and scrape
huge amounts of people's data uh
conversations and stuff it didn't exist
in 50 years ago so we maybe we do need
new
new rules and functions but the thing is
de facto whoever can do it is gonna do
it so i saw uh
hassan [ __ ] tweeted you know you know
left-wing guy he said something about
liking
watching steven crowder cry to to defund
the fbi or whatever and i'm like hasn't
crowder ragged in the fbi for a really
really long time yeah this isn't new
yeah no i mean you know so i'm like i
hear your brother hassan you know when
you're like cheering for steven crowder
talking about defunding the fbi and i'm
like many of us have been there for a
while now maybe maybe if you agree with
that
maybe there's like a caucus that can be
formed between progressives and
republicans where it's like okay we all
agree we're gonna get rid of that one
maybe the atf while we're at it i mean
they don't like the government right
supposedly so how about we all just say
uh you know um
abolish many of these
doj dhs institutions huh how about that
i'm all in for getting rid of the
three-letter agencies i think it's time
you look at their track record i'm a big
like that you can tell a tree by the
fruit and the fruit of the fbi has been
nothing but tyranny that seems very
corporate in nature for the last two
three decades and this goes all the way
back to you're right the 70s
and even i would argue even further than
that but the fbi is an institution the
cia is an institution
um that
has such uh political agenda to it that
it's impossible to claim that they're
biased and that's you even had people
today
um like andrew yang that was calling
that out that was willing to admit that
like this looks political in nature and
so when people's immediate de facto
response at this point is like oh
there's the fbi being political again
like that's a sign that the tree is
rotten the fruit's rotten this thing
needs to just be uprooted
yeah 100 this is the first time i've
ever retweeted andrew cuomo because he
was on it quicker than some of these
republicans same for andrew yang but you
know why he was on it okay first he's
worried right right yes
i will first say
i can respect that uh cuomo came out and
said the right thing right i will give
him credit for that
i will then add maybe the guy who killed
15 000 people by putting covet patients
in nursing homes might be a little
worried about what the government's
going to do when they go after
politicians he's sitting in his living
room and he sees the news he goes wait
we're doing that now i thought we were
off limits no no no no no we gotta
yeah yeah yeah when it comes for you man
that's the problem with the
weaponization of all this stuff but uh
i don't know i don't i don't know how
the republicans
i don't know what the republicans would
even do kevin mccarthy's acting like
he's like mark your calendar merrick
garland because when we get in in
november we're gonna send you more
sternly worded letters while you
continually destroy this country i don't
understand why
what like worst case scenario or even
just like normal case scenario if trump
were to get elected again and to get an
office like what would be what would be
that that's gonna fire him maybe maybe
people will get fired maybe that's what
this is about but like really the threat
of our country is not there there's no
like oh maybe something is gonna
devastate like we're okay it's the
economy is bad and we need to fix the
economy regardless of who's the power
the bureaucratic state
has been in power for too long and they
will not let an elected official
remove them from power
there is this parasitic entity that is
the bureaucratic state latched onto our
country suckling away and controlling it
like a brain slug and donald trump is
trying to remove it but it's almost
impossible it is resisting
these people aren't elected they get
appointed they stay in through numerous
administrations the civil servants so i
have to we've talked about on the show
you know a president gets in the off
gets in office they're like i'm gonna
get the troops out of the middle east
and then a bunch of documents that are
dead on the desk and they say no you're
going to bomb this guy this guy and this
guy he goes
i'm going to block kids and that's
exactly what happens so when donald
trump gets in this is my theory my
hypothesis
they say okay mr president you're the
president fine boom they slam the files
in the desk this is our agenda this is
what we do and he goes
no no we're not doing any of that that's
stupid i don't know i don't know why you
want to do that and then they start
saying no you don't understand like
we're the cia like we do these things
this is what we're doing and why because
don't know don't care how does it help
america
and they're like okay we gotta stop this
guy
i think there was a point
uh before trump got elected he had a
meeting with a bunch of like
establishment figures i was in dc for
apparently he was like in a building
somewhere
and i bet they were like if you win will
you play ball and he said if i win i'm
the president and we're going to do what
america wants
and then i think these people were like
okay that's it he can't win he can't be
allowed to win so i'll give you a real
i'll give you an example our our middle
eastern agenda i talk about it often the
qatar turkey pipeline we had a
multi-presidential agenda doesn't matter
who the president is we were doing this
building these pipelines trying to get
energy into europe competing with russia
donald trump comes in and goes no excuse
me no and he shuts it all down
shut down the tpp too
oh that was like kicking them in the
balls
so they're shrieking yeah now donald
trump says i'm gonna fire all of them
schedule f and they're just losing their
minds
so this is what you get when you have
unelected bureaucrats who actually run
your country
ray signed off on this little people are
saying okay i want to pretend to know
what was going on in the inner workings
of this
but this they they know what they're
doing
they are trying to stop someone from
being able to become the duly elected
president for a second this is also like
you don't this is kennedy he came out he
was like i'm gonna break up the cia and
then kennedy got assassinated like you
don't threaten the cia if you're going
to fire people you just do it when you
have the ability to do it you don't like
tell them all ahead of time you're going
to do it well let me ask you like do you
know what the if like why leave
why
what was the motivation of lee harvey
oswald
yeah what the origin the actual story is
like what's the what what an angry
communist fidel castro sympathizer and
is that like kennedy yeah
i mean that maybe i guess that's the
story yeah it's a story but he was
working with groups that were i think
what happened was he loaned a group of
radicals his gun and then they placed
they they killed kennedy and put his gun
in the building well didn't kennedy want
to get us stopped vietnam or something
like that
yeah he was a pretty anti-war guy in
general why would he escalate he's
actually escalating vietnam he was
escalating yeah but he but he had always
said that there was a power greater than
him that was manufacturing a lot of the
crises that were happening remember he
was like there's that famous quote that
kennedy was basically saying that i'm
not fully the one in charge here there's
a whole different thing happening behind
the curtain and and then obviously he's
taken out also he and his brother bobby
went hard on the mob hard on the mob
yeah so they think maybe the mob was
involved in killing him do you guys want
to pull back the curtain a little bit
yes all right take a look at this story
from the new york post no the judge who
okayed the mar-a-lago raid is an obama
donor once linked to jeffrey epstein
what now i stated this at the end of the
show when i heard the news
i said yeah yeah it was a what is
epstein epstein-linked mean it's like
his brother once catered a restaurant
epstein served internet you know you get
these sensational headlines and then i
read it and it was he was a federal
prosecutor who abruptly switched sides
joining the defense for jeffrey epstein
for his lieutenants not for epstein's
specifically
and uh
okay that's weird check it out
reinhardt was elevated to magistrate
judge in 2018 after 10 years in private
practice
that november the miami herald reported
that he had represented several of
epstein's employees
including by reinhardt's own admission
to the outlet epstein's pilots his
scheduler sarah kellen and nadia
marcinkova who epstein once reportedly
reportedly described as his yugoslavian
sex slave kellen kallen and martin kova
were among epstein's lieutenants who
were granted immunity as part of a
controversial 2007 deal with federal
prosecutors that allowed him to plead
guilty to state charges rather than
federal crimes epstein wound up serving
just 13 months in county jail and was
granted work release
that's really really interesting in the
miami herald story they mention
actually look they say
he donated to barack obama's
presidential campaign months after he
left the local use attorney's office to
rep employees of the convicted peto
jeffrey epstein who had received
immunity in the long-running trafficking
investigation of the financier financier
so this guy
was accused
many are arguing i guess his his
side of it was
he didn't have any private information
or anything
they say 10 months after starting work
for epstein's co-conspirators according
to the federal election commission
reinhardt gave one thousand dollars
directly to the obama campaign another
thousand dollars to its fundraising arm
the obama victory fund though the
records show the judge made mostly small
dollar donations blah blah blah i don't
know uh how much i care about the
donation stuff
but i think what's interesting is that
he's basically accused of flipping sides
in a 2013 court filing reinhardt's
former colleagues contradicted him
saying he had learned confidential
non-public public information about the
epstein matter while employed by the u.s
attorney's office
reinhart noted to the herald in response
that a complaint filed against him by a
lawyer for epstein's victims had been
dismissed in a 2011 affidavit reinhardt
denied he had done anything improper and
insisted that since he was not involved
in the federal investigation of epstein
he was not privy to inside information
about the case as recently as january
2015 reinhardt was asked to appear on
newsmax to give analysis on the epstein
fallout but declined to uh to publicly
note his own role in the case
okay
maybe
it's just he's a judge in the area
that's all it is right
maybe it's just one big coincidence my
favorite conspiracy theory right now
donald trump apparently took classified
documents to mar-a-lago
the conspiracy theory is
he took the as he took it as leverage
from his time as president i mean look
people were saying that if trump lost
they would lock him up right
and so now the theory is trump took
leverage
they're trying to get the leverage back
that being said
i do believe the simple solution in the
absence of evidence is simply that trump
had a bunch of staffers grabbing boxes
from the white house when he was leaving
some of those boxes had documents that's
about it but if that's all that it is
like if i if i said this today if i was
on the left right now and if i was a big
you know anti-trump person i would be
furious at the fbi right now i'd be
furious at this judge because if you
shoot the king and miss like your your
whole case is destroyed you just made
the best possible argument for trump
2024 so if it's really just oh well
there's a few boxes that got pulled from
some staffers and ended up in his house
and that was enough to issue this whole
raid on his house and you saw today the
fbi saying we don't like the word raid
stop using raids so then you saw msnbc
go in real time and change the word raid
to a oh a routine search warrant and so
if it's all that it was it's just some
boxes got left behind like they just
made the case for trump 2024 which says
to me i mean i believe they know that
yeah that going after a sitting
president is a very very serious matter
so they
really wanted whatever those documents
were
again look
when it comes to conspiracy theories
they're fun i'd love to believe in a
world where trump is behind the scenes
and he's like walking down the hallway
and they're like mr former president we
have the plan we have the the documents
here and he's like they don't know who
they're up against
but in reality it's like some intern
grabbed a box and he's just like what
are they searching for they're in my
safe and then they find a box and it's
like just routine confidential nonsense
is trump the mastermind everybody wants
to be is there a deep underground is
there a cabal is there a secret
conspiracy are the elites at war uh
i don't think he's a mastermind but i do
think you you nailed it earlier when you
were talking about some of the agencies
in the deep state that he's his
presidency exposed like how big that rot
was so i think trump's a guy more than
anything that's just honest and pretty
bombastic in nature and so he came in
and he's going with his playbook and
there are a lot of people in the way of
that playbook and i don't think it was
because of his genius 4d chess i think
he was just being different than any
president we've ever had and in turn it
blew up a lot of the
china that was in the oval office and in
the bureaucratic establishment of dc and
then all of a sudden we're realizing
that like whoa the mess is way deeper
than we realized and so we credit that
to trump but trump's just being who he
is trump just came in like a bull in a
china shop and knocked everything over
and in turn we're learning like whoa
this is this stench is rotten i think
you know what i've said in the past
about trump is that he slips on a banana
peel but pulls a perfect backflip yes
like you watch
oh and then
like the ukraine gate yeah the phone
call he had with uh with the
i think it was lindsay yeah was was
funny because he was like what's this
thing we're hearing about joe biden and
the prosecutor i don't know could you
look into that and it was like they
tried painting trump as this nefarious
like 4d chess mastermind who was
orchestrating sabotaging joe biden's
candidacy when in reality the reality
was he was on twitter and he saw a video
someone retweeted of biden saying if you
don't fire the prosecutor you don't get
the billion dollars and then trump's
like oh i better call this guy and ask
him he's like what is that and so
they're like he's a mastermind trying to
sabotage biden
he probably slept on a banana banana
peel but it worked yeah it worked now we
all know about it so more forest gump
than adolf hitler is what you're saying
yeah yeah exactly that's a good way to
that's a really good one he's not
thinking ten steps ahead yeah
and if and it works out because he's i
actually you know
people believe what they want about
trump that's fine i my big thing is that
i believe he means what he says um
especially related to his motivations
around things honestly he's pretty
forward about his own self-interest in a
lot of dealings but his self-interest
ends up helping the american people in a
lot of ways this was his campaign in
2016 is like this pro-america
nationalist sort of mentality around
things like manufacturing and the
economy in general like that resonated
with american people because by being
himself in turn it was really fighting
for the interest that americans finally
felt like were represented by a
political candidate
and i i just
you know i'm i'm chilling
things may be bad the night is always
darker for the dawn but from 2016 to now
when you think about how the
establishment lost control it's kind of
funny yeah
the shot and freud of their failures is
oh yeah he gave me a psychic jolt of
like the you as an american can take
care of yourself and your your immediate
reality but it also i've started to
think about the military-industrial
complex and i used to be very hateful of
it and critical of it but now i'm like
there's gonna be one on earth there's
gonna be an overarching military is it
going to be one that the u.s controls or
is going to be one that china controls i
want to make sure i issue a
clarification because it may have
sounded as if we were saying he does
have class of information i don't know
that yeah that's just the accusation
people people are claiming that the feds
did seize the documents they were
looking for i don't know if that's good
i saw these tweets where they're like
well if they went in there that means
they had to have gotten a warrant which
means he was must have been committing a
crime i'm like what in the hell kind of
yeah
reverse logic did you do well they don't
believe in the fifth of the listen until
proven guilty and i
just because they say they found
something doesn't mean they found
something we gotta you know you really
need evidence here we gotta display
evidence i don't like the patriotic i
don't like that people can can detain
people without recourse this is insane
are you even trying to understand the
banality of evil
these are people who are who are
cheering for the idea guilty until
proven innocent
well i don't hear innocent people
getting raided by the fbi so clearly it
must mean trump's guilty if you have
nothing to hide then let them spy on you
like no that's not how it works man you
have the right to privacy yeah and i
tweeted something the other day about
the irs and how these 87 000 agents are
coming and they're going to make your
life worse in every conceivable way and
someone said well you shouldn't be
worried if you don't have anything to
hide and i'm like so i should be fine
with surveillance because i don't have
anything to hide that's the exact same
argument like what about your balls yeah
right like if you're putting cameras
everywhere maybe you don't want people
looking at your body and also what if
they pass some new law where it's like
it's illegal to be a human and then
they're like you're like or it's illegal
to walk outside on t like you can't make
a stupid law and then yeah uh spy on
someone to see if they're violating your
stupid law and then bust them for that
yeah just because your conscience is
clean and you're not doing anything
wrong doesn't mean you should have your
house broken into especially when you're
the former president of the united
states with all the political
implications that come with that and
then even this representative from
pennsylvania like he just said what
happened agents walked up took his phone
they could have gone through the lawyers
there would have been a cordial process
but it was that nope you know what we
believe you're guilty already and we're
just going to yank it they want to make
sure you didn't delete anything off this
phone but like they gave hillary clinton
plenty of time to discuss she
smashed with hammers yeah of course she
was working with the dnc and the
democratic establishment i don't like
calling i don't want to play democrat
republican here she's with that liberal
economic order um and i don't think this
guy was
fair point is that trump has not been
charged with anything
and they did take hillary clinton's
server and and and scan through it and
read every email
so
yeah i saw some pretty damning stuff
come out of her emails oh yeah oh i mean
there was a hundred i mean well for one
the wikileaks stuff yeah dc cc and
things like that but uh she had 110
classified emails so
people are pointing out now like yeah
well they did it to hillary and she
didn't get charged with the crime and
trump's not being charged with the crime
and it's like yes we understand there's
a double standard
yeah they're they're not going to come
out and be like well trump did it but so
did hillary no they're going to be like
trump did it lock them up
i'm getting the feeling people are like
starting to accept that it's like uh
just okay maybe the government is kind
of dirty and evil and they got a side
that they want you to be on but i just
want to be on that side then let's just
keep doing our life let's keep having
sunday cookouts and eating watermelon
and life's gonna be dandelions but like
uh at some point you gotta stand up for
righteousness itself and and like
not just be in a club i don't know man
maybe that's not true maybe it's like
pick your tribe and that's how it's
always been
i don't know i yeah no i don't know how
you would go to sleep at night if i knew
what was right and i don't do it it's
that exact thing i'm denying
righteousness i'm denying the
opportunity to make change i think
people have lost the hope that they can
make change which is a deeper issue
because i think they feel like okay well
the establishment's in place and clearly
it's not moving if they're willing to go
after the former president like they can
destroy my life i think there's a level
of hopelessness but my big encouragement
to people all the time is like that
happened over the course of a few
decades it can be reversed over the
course of a few decades as well like all
you need is someone to come in into
different positions of power in regions
around the country that basically strip
everything out one thing that i'm
excited about that i was disappointed in
trump even going back to this
conversation in 2016 is he had all these
hopes of draining the swamp he gets in
he refuses to fire a lot of the people
that made the problems really really bad
his worst mistake was that he had
personnel around him that was really
detrimental
now i think if it was to be him or
anyone in 2024 you're right ian
everything is so out in the open that
it's like you can't deny it anymore you
have to uproot or else we're not going
to make it moving forward this is why
they they won't allow a power change
exactly this is this is the democratic
establishment the democrats and many
conservatives
rejecting the peaceful transition of
power but they're doing it early
it's funny because there's viral tweets
jack besovic retweeted one guy who's who
was criticizing trump over a ukraine
gate saying he was going after his
political rival
and it's like are where are you now
yeah because because what's what's the
difference yeah if that was your
argument yeah
joe biden didn't announce he was running
for president no one thought he was
gonna yeah they didn't think he's a
frontrunner and the funny thing is many
progressives who are bernie progressives
were telling me like he's clearly going
after biden i'm like aren't you a bernie
supporter like what makes you think
biden is the front runner why why
wouldn't trump be going after bernie he
was the guy everyone was talking about
they're like oh wow
you know in regards to what you're
saying michael about winding it back
like it took us 20 years from the
patriot act to get to this crazy
surveillance state that we could wind it
back i don't know if that's true because
the digital data is there to be scraped
and it's like we have to
go forward and create like um encryption
like levels of quantum encryption that
even government agencies and and
military complex machines can't hack if
that's possible um
and it's like
there's no it's like an avalanche and
we're not going to make the avalanche go
back uphill you just got to figure out
how to build a suit so that you can swim
the avalanche and not get crushed by the
snow what does reversing course mean for
individuals anyway
in what in what context
in this transfer of power well because
we complied with it for two decades
like we we've done the things we've
danced the dance we've done what they've
told us to we bought the stuff from
china we sacrificed our convictions and
what made america special on the altars
of cheap convenience we did the things
so that we could have levels of ease and
convenience in the marketplace and our
travel experience and et cetera and i
think part of reverting course in my
mind looks like the average american
standing up and just detaching from that
system anymore saying i'm not going to
keep going along with it and so we saw a
lot of that happen in the past year with
kovid and the whole vaccine mandate
stuff is you had people finally get
pushed to a brink where they said like
my job's on the line but i don't care my
convictions are so strong that i'll let
them fire me
and they'll take away the demand and
then you see companies start to revert
course because of that i think that's
how we do it for a lot of people it
wasn't just about convictions it was
just a stress test yeah some people were
like i'm just done i'd rather sleep
under a bench i'd rather just sleep in
the street than deal with all of this
stuff
let me pull up this next story
we have this tweet from talk radio 77
wabc
breaking news
palm beach authorities on alert about
armed protesters expected at mar-a-lago
and i love uh i love the comments people
are saying things like it's gonna be a
bunch of guys in polo shirts khaki
shorts and sunglasses
with short trim hair and that's right
fed boys
so i don't know if there's any
developments on this or how much this
story is legit
but we did see a bunch of people out in
front of mar-a-lago protesting and
cheering for trump
and so when i see a story like this
for one
fed boys that's basically what everybody
is saying that they're going to come out
and it's going to
you know
what would you call it i guess a false
flag oh oh i see what you're saying yeah
yeah the feds are going to come out
pretending to be
trump supporters or something and
not just that they're going to lure
groups
who aren't part of the fed to
participate but then
maybe
there's there's the hanging threat that
the feds are going to incite violence
and then blame it on the ordinary people
they learned there
exactly that's what happened to january
6th right yeah well
we don't we don't unfair if we don't we
don't know that they're taking
responsibilities like with ray epps that
he had been a plant no one really i
don't even know if that's ever been
confirmed did he used to work for the
fbi or anything i don't i don't i don't
know or care about um
to speculate on ray epps because of what
they're trying to do to manipulate that
story my point is my point of this is
simple let's approach it from hey
there's a guy on camera inciting
violence you should arrest them
yeah yeah that's the target not the
instead what they're doing is they're
using the fact that people have claimed
conspiracy theory to discredit the
entirety of the right apps
was yelling like let's go to the capital
stuff
oh yeah yeah he's on video like very
busy let me tell you guys about about
this tactic used by leftists for a long
time
what they do is
they'll get a handful of people
they
will organize a peaceful protest
so they can get mass and let's say
everybody come down and march and raise
your fist
they they they will coordinate different
groups with their strategy
they'll say some people's job is to
obstruct so they'll convince people like
hey stand here the people don't know
what they're doing right when they go
for a peaceful protest they have no idea
the plan of the organizers the pawn has
no idea that the knight is about to move
next and so what they'll do is
they have
aggressors basically that will mix in
the crowd and incite the violence
because they want to do two things they
need the cover of a mass group to be
able to engage in violence and get away
and they also want videos of these
regular people being beaten by cops
so they will start the fight the regular
person will get hit they will then go to
their regular person and say why were
the cops hitting you what oh can you you
got to join us man that's how they
recruit
that's the plan that's how the fbi
works to perpetuate its own existence
they create the reasons that they
supposedly exist right look at uh the
whitmer thing yeah great example yeah
what was it like
they were all informants yeah it was
like one guy that wasn't
the poor guy just got brought it and
that's what they do they'll target the
lonely people that are isolated from
community and they'll lead them to feel
like they're part of some movement and
it's all these feds that are inviting
them into creating a problem that
requires them to be the solution and
there are a lot of people that do this
in in the corporate world too i mean
george soros gets accused of this often
right putting money toward destruction
so that he can come in and profit off
the cleanup you know there's there's a
lot there that we've seen this time and
time again part of the reason i'm so
frustrated with the fbi and their
dealings is that it's not just what
they're doing like this trump scenario
like this guy with his phone
it's also what they're not doing so in
the process of spending all of their
time sending all these agents to trump's
home they're ignoring the fact that the
current president's son we have him on
video and photo evidence instances where
the guy is dealing in incredibly illegal
activity and they're silent or larry
nassar silent that's hilarious the
gymnastics usa gymnastics i don't know
about this tell me about it yeah abusing
the girls yeah and the fbi knew about
them yeah they knew they knew about
epstein yeah they knew about epstein i
mean the examples are endless and you're
absolutely right oftentimes they they
need to boost their budget they need to
create problems so that they can
exemplify why they're needed as a
solution another example that i think is
industrial agricultural pharmaceutical
like this thing where they'll feed
people bread that's
sprayed with glyphosate the wheat as a
desiccant to dry it out before harvest
that makes people just like grotesquely
ill and then they create
pills that will you know treat it and
then so they're not only creating the
glyphosate or these i don't know if it's
all the same people but they're creating
the chemicals that to put on the food
that make the people sick then they make
the medicines to
it's it's it's
make people sick
yeah a lot of times they do a lot of
times the treatments make people more
sick than the diseases themselves it's
it's a terrible um
reality of of using like experimental
medicine on a population it's it's
devastating well a perfect example
recently is um that i'm not insinuating
anything youtube um but pfizer is upping
their uh
intentionality with heart issue
medicine so issues like myocarditis
pushing prescriptions that solve that
issue you make your conclusions as to
why
but yes it's this exact thing pfizer and
these big pharmaceutical companies
they're they operate by the same
playbook was it wasn't there like a
document recently
i saw some story where they basically
said we should reconsider curing
diseases do you think you saw that
that's the last type of headline you
could expect oh i hope you guys got that
on you google that look it up
i saw that on twitter they were like we
should reconsider i can't remember where
i saw been maybe it may actually be an
old story like reconsider i remember
that yeah it was something about like is
it a story or just an opinion piece no i
think i saw it was a document from i
could be wrong that's why i'm saying
fact check it because i i just saw it
from a drug company and they were like
it's not really monetarily wise to cure
diseases we just need to
sell those these pills let me look it up
i'm seeing from popsci.com we're closer
to curing all diseases than we think
uh they're like curing blindness i mean
we're if we can actually heal the blind
and let the blind see again a lot of
people think they have the cure to
cancer and are hiding it from everyone
oh that's they have to pay for the
treatment the truth is that cancer comes
from so many different sources there's
not like a single cure for cancer so i
understand the thinking because the the
cost of fixing cancer is extremely
lucrative but did you find it i mean i
found a story oh [ __ ] from medpage today
curing patients is bad for business well
yes apparently they say an article by
take him on cnbc goldman sachs issued a
report so it's not not a drug company
that suggested that drug developers
might want to think twice about making
drugs that were too effective
what do you say the potential to deliver
one-shot cures is one of the most
attractive aspects of gene therapy
genetically engineered cell therapy and
gene editing however such treatments
offer a very different outlook with
regard to recurring revenue versus
chronic therapies while the proposition
carries tremendous value for patients
and society it could represent a
challenge for genome medicine developers
looking for sustained cash flow oh
medicine developers looking for cash
flows is it so gross isn't the first
lipo ever still on and has been on for
like 100 years in like a firehouse in
new york or something like that wow i
don't know yeah can you pull that up
about that
the the the argument the idea was that
they needed
planned obsolescence otherwise you'd
sell a light bulb and then you'd never
sell another one too effective
too effective well yeah i found the
article from cnbc that says goldman
sachs asks in a biotech research report
is curing patients a sustainable
business model and i guess it kind of
makes sense that it's not which makes us
then ask why yeah 2018 we have it right
here cnbc for a few years just use gene
therapy that wears off and you need to
boost it yeah you need more boosters or
or how about
a two-stage gene therapy the first one
cures it the second one starts it back
up yeah just a perpetual cycle or a
subscription a subscription
wait how about it cures the disease but
also gives you a different disease
that requires paying us a one-for-one
program yeah that's okay yeah swap like
violence if violence is the disease then
the military-industrial complex is the
is the treatment it's not a cure it's a
treatment because if they cure the
violence then they're no longer
necessary and then we won't have any
reason to fund the military but then
that's the because they're afraid that
violence will strike again that it'll
never truly be gone and they're just
saying with illness illness will never
truly be gone so if we stop making
medicine we won't be prepared when a
when a big one comes when an asteroid
land or a comet lands that has a
bacterium on it that causes some new
disease that pfizer wasn't ready for
i understand that living in fear like
that i just it comes to a point where
you got to not try and profit off of the
pain and suffering of humans so
you know i was talking about this
earlier
there is a and the other day there's a
point in history when you look at major
historical moments
like uh
spanish civil war or the russian
revolution or uh nazi germany when
people left
they moved to other countries and
survived
and i i'd always read and ask them like
why did your family flee what made them
realize
and you know nazi germany obviously
being the obvious one because of how bad
things got
they say things like the demonization of
these groups and we were like they're
targeting us but then the question is
why do people stay
and a lot of people stayed thinking it
could never happen and it wouldn't get
worse
and so i was thinking about like crystal
knocked right you're familiar yeah uh
the broken glass yeah tell me tell me
elevator pitch i'm familiar but in case
people don't know
people went around smashing up jewish
jewish jewish businesses it was like in
one night in germany nazi germany um i'm
not i don't know the full historical
details other than the general idea it
was in one night yeah yeah
there was yeah it was a pattern that
went on for weeks but it was one
specific night crystal knocked yeah
night of the broken glass that was like
lived in infamy because it was this
horrible night that
the country it was sort of like a
rubicon moment where it's like you guys
just crossed a major line that's going
to be impossible to come back from and
then it just de-escalated into
everything that nazi germany became it
escalated indefinitely yeah
the country de-escalated that's a better
way to word it so
you know i've read about people who said
like when that happened they were like
we have to get out of here
and then there are a lot of people who
didn't and it's like when something like
that happens why didn't you get out yeah
they weren't activated socially that's
for sure those people did nothing
no i think it's because we have the gift
of hindsight yeah so i'll give you an
example um aoc comes out and fabricates
a story about january 6. that the cop
someone knocked on her door and said
where is she
where is she
and she's like i'm hiding in the
bathroom and i thought this is it i'm
going to die or whatever she said i
don't know
that story happened an hour before
anyone had breached the capitol a full
hour she had no idea however in
hindsight she knows most people don't
know the details of the day all they
know is people stormed the capitol so if
she tells this story it sounds like this
thing happened
when we read history and we read about
krystal knocked and things like that we
think
well how could they not have seen it
coming yeah only because we know what
did happen
today
i don't mean to imply that what's
happening now is identical to what's
happened in nazi germany or anything
like that history doesn't repeat it
rhymes there are similarities
take a look at anything that's happened
in the past couple of years and ask
yourself why you haven't fled
because you don't know what lies ahead
and so for us to look back on history
and know what the end result was we'd
say clearly at that point i'd get out
would you would you really any of you
maybe after i don't know billions of
dollars in damage when a when a
marxist political faction ransacked this
country from the biggest cities of small
town when we have quotes from a guy who
said there was fighting in his building
and he called the police in new york and
they said sir the city is under attack
what would you have us do
when we saw
riots in almost every in almost every
major city
two billion dollars was the insurance
cap on the damage 30 plus dead and
everyone says this is right
maybe
it will become something worse and then
i wonder if in 50 years people will look
back at the summer of love and say
why didn't they get out when that
happened when when you had black lives
matter an identitarian
marxist organization
smashing things up organizing
destruction
they did they thought everything was
fine
well i'll tell you this a lot of people
have already fled to mexico we read that
story we thought it was funny
yeah a lot of people are going to el
salvador max kaiser max keiser
prominently and stacey herbert have gone
to el salvador because they're huge
maximalists for bitcoin and that they've
adopted bitcoin as a national currency
in el salvador el salvador yeah yeah el
salvador
and uh like einstein fled the nazis
einstein fled like what and early 36 33
or 35 yeah way way early so that's just
a question i have i mean so we're now at
the point where
the department of justice under one
political faction
has just raided the home
of the
the front runner of the rival political
faction several members of his his
administration have been arrested
they have now seized the phone of an
active member of congress
like at what point are you like hey
we're kind of in the thick of things
where usually in history we learned
about the people who survived or the
ones who fled i will say
many people don't flee because they're
like this is my country and i will not
let it collapse that's me man i can't
you know we live in california and so
it's california is where everyone else
will be in 10 years i mean you're from
new york same deal um any of these big
blue kind of metropolitan progressive
authoritarian strongholds um the
california lifestyle at this point is so
blatantly not in our favor that it's
like if you're gonna stay it's because
you have to feel a special sort of
conviction to stay so i don't blame
anyone that's left to texas that goes to
a red state and sets up shop there good
for you it makes sense for us though
it's like man there's there's there's
something holding me here that i can't
leave and in the same way in the united
states it's like we're it's gonna get
worse before it gets better i i don't
this is our country i can't leave no
matter where you flee you run into more
problems anywhere you go
yeah geez you see the way they handle
people new zealand the way they handle
lockdowns in australia kicking people's
doors in and
el salvador have their own problems
right that i don't think we want to deal
with you know when we're talking about
all this mexico is doing pretty well
i've been thinking a lot about fleeing
and like where would i go what would i
do but i think what's happening is the
united states is freaking awesome and
the state's control is really an awesome
part of why but people are fleeing but
they're fleeing states yes it's it
that's what the that you see the people
they got out early they got out last
year they got out with coveted locks
that's a sign of people losing their
allegiance to their state in their local
area though i wanna i wanna definitely
indication
uh
germany if that's an example is what
roughly the size of texas or comparable
smaller a little smaller than that i
think
um we're a big country yeah when the
summer of love happened
we did get out
we we left the south jersey suburbs and
came to west virginia western maryland
and west virginia right so i literally
was like i'm getting out of this place
right so this is crazy there's a couple
reasons why people wouldn't leave first
of all because they don't have the money
to do so like right now i don't have the
funds to back up and move to el salvador
i have no idea where i would work or
what i would do if i were to do that and
the other reason that people would not
leave the us and ostensibly some of
their states is that there is nowhere
else to go and i know that like steve
hilton stays in california because he
thinks that maybe he can save it and he
has people who agree with him
i have heard that much of california is
not insane crazy l.a we're not right
they're all orange county they're like
insane right there's some actual
conservatives over in california because
there are a lot of people there there
are a lot of reasons to stay in the u.s
and i feel like this is just something
we're going to have to go through i
don't know what else to say
let me pull up this story from yahoo
news
hillary clinton promotes but her emails
merch after fbi search of trump's
mar-a-lago
so her her fundraiser pitch is i did
something way worse
got away with it and now you're going to
give me money oh my god the day after
his house got raided literally 12 hours
what is happening
and she has that like um photoshop
picture of her looking like a younger
picture of her with her huge all that
work done on those cheekbones like
hey look look look i don't i don't i
don't care about the merch stuff
trump has dropped targeted merch he's
he's also made fun of democrats in a
similar way we really are seeing the
left try to learn from how the right did
meme warfare with like the dark brandon
trying they're really important they do
you see this they made a nazi meme of of
joe biden and then they unironically
posted it and people were like what are
you doing like that was made to make fun
of joe biden why are you posting do you
have that image available nazi memes
dark brandon rises and then go to images
wasn't there a thought that this was a
was it you and i'm sorry about this yeah
that there was like this was like a
chinese app type deal yeah i wasn't able
to confirm this i saw something on
twitter i know everything i was super
curious yeah i really want to look into
that
so so we have it right here this is the
eagle
so this is a mockery of the dark knight
rises where there's a bat
in the in like there's a skyscraper and
he's looking down and there's like a bat
in the buildings and so they did this
eagle
which many people pointed out is very
similar to the the nazi eagle and he
looks like vladimir lenin in that
picture yeah what's going on
you know
hey maybe you guys when people make
memes to make fun of joe biden and then
you just take them and repost them you
should probably look into what you're
doing yeah
yeah was this supposed to be endearing
they're just illiterate to the internet
this is like in your face like if it
does if history looks back and like this
is when the united states went full like
totalitarian and then you see that image
and they're like oh they just blatantly
told everyone he was doing gonna do it
yeah well i mean but like joe biden
doesn't even know this meme exists yeah
you see the video of him trying to shake
chuck schumer's hand twice oh my gosh
that was weird and the jacket just held
it there yeah well no he shakes so he's
like chuck schumer talks turns around
shakes biden's hand by to put his hand
down and then looks and then pulls his
hand out again and he stares at him and
then like puts it to his face
i can't imagine living in the fever
dream that experiences on a daily basis
they're like bringing bts into the white
house and he's like hi
who are you and they don't speak any
english this what's bts
k-pop oh okay
what does bts mean it's a good question
you're right though on the fundraising
piece do you um do you remember last
year when there was that video that came
out attacking desantis because they
didn't want him to
get credit for how awesome florida's
doing so they basically tried to
showcase that florida's this terrible
place full of freedom and it was like
this lovely video of all these people
smiling and laughing and they're like
they don't take mass seriously and it's
this family walking on the beach so
happy it's like yeah you guys don't
realize but you keep shooting yourself
in the foot when you try to do stuff
like this yeah yeah yeah
trump's done similar things and and
trump supporters have done similar
things in terms of making targeted merch
but my point on the whole thing is like
coming out and being like we got away
with it not give us money it's kind of
like
you know
people are already worried about a
double standard and an imbalance in the
justice system
cackling while you raise money off of it
is probably not going to help this
country no
but you know the funny thing is many of
these democrats think donald trump is
the one who's committing all the crimes
because they don't read the news
dude what is up with
people are obsessed with the cult like
it's but what i mean is the cult worship
of the humans like this politic i'm all
about politics and understanding the way
government works and
how many people you need to hire to be
in the republic and to facilitate the
transfer of power but like when you get
obsessed about the individuals and
you're like well joe biden if you some
people talk about joe biden then another
person's like yeah but trump like that
has nothing to do with what i'm talking
about right now i don't
like let's focus on and
it's like it's a video game or like a
movie and they're talking about their
favorite characters or the villains they
hate like
it so seems so detached from reality of
like you better get enough food for your
kids like or for yourself we gotta
really focus on making sure we we we
reach our basic necessities
yeah the the people who live in cities
for the most part have no idea no when
it comes to basic necessities now i was
arguing with a guy in fa on on twitter
once it was really funny was a yang
supporter
and uh like i was i was a big fan of
yang early on i think he's done things i
don't agree with but he's all right he's
you know whatever i love him but he uh
he was talking about ubi and i was like
i agree with like he's created this huge
extensive policy list he's really
thought about i respect that but ubi
makes no sense
i asked some guy we were arguing and i
can't remember exactly what the context
was why we brought it up but i mentioned
like
eventually there's not going to be food
in supermarkets or eventually people
will be able to source things like milk
if there's no one who's you know who's
doing base level jobs or we have to
create a surf class and he's like what
do you mean the milk's at the store
and then i was like i was like yeah but
like the milk won't come
from the production to the store so
people can't get it he's like what are
you talking about people just go to the
store to get milk and then i was like
the store won't have milk when the
people that bottle it don't sell it to
them and he's like i don't know what
you're trying to say and i'm like whoa
oh my gosh did you guys see the video
last week of the girl that's the farmer
who is showcasing the bale of hay in her
trunk did you guys know and she was
talking about how much the price has
skyrocketed of her hay
that she has to get to feed her cattle
that then produce the milk and the meat
um and so she talks about how her hay is
like quadrupled in the last 12 months
and her warning to everyone is this will
be passed on to you this fall of course
like if you think that this is isolated
wait till it hits the shopping centers
and you see your price of beef and of
milk skyrocket because to feed these
animals is becoming so incredibly
expensive even chickens yeah even
chicken here's the other thing people
need to understand too we give our we
give these animals corn now there are a
lot of farms you come out here yeah and
we see the cows eating grass all day you
got the chickens they're eating feed
they're in layer but they're eating bugs
but in a lot of places it's it's just
corn that factory farmed salmon corn
yes subsidized yeah really gross i need
to reclaim my name's heritage i don't
know if this is true but i heard that
tilapia are fed in farms uh underneath
these cages um
or like
wire platforms that chickens are above
them and like
crap into crap into the water and then
the tilapia eat it
and that's like how they feed the
tilapia i don't think it's possible that
goes into grocery stores i hope not i
don't think that's possible because the
chicken chickens have one hole a cloaca
yeah and there's like there's
like a hen has three things they have
like where the egg comes from and they
have like the poop and the peep and it
mixes together yeah so you've got your
so it would poison the waters yes and
they couldn't do it yeah the water would
just become i hope it's not true i don't
want it to be true i remember working in
the restaurant industry for like 15
years you know up until about five or
six years ago and they uh they would
talk a lot about farm farmed uh tilapia
it was way nasty it was like one of the
nastiest fish you could ever order from
a restaurant is farm you want wild
tilapia if you're ever gonna get tilapia
i don't know why though and maybe it has
something to do with that maybe not you
know what i'd prefer to believe you know
people who believe in these big
conspiracies you know like i don't think
there's a grand global cabal
i think there are powerful interests
vying for power and colluding behind the
scenes so the epstein stuff like well i
mean
maxwell was convicted like we know they
were doing this stuff and we know they
were they were connected with powerful
individuals maybe it was blackmail or
whatever but they clearly didn't have
full control because epstein is no
longer alive and maxwell is locked up so
it wasn't you know i don't think that
there's one like illuminati or something
like that i just think powerful just do
this stuff i'd prefer to believe that
aliens controlled everything it's if i'm
gonna believe something
you know as grandiose i'm gonna i'm
gonna shoot for the stars they do
literally and assume it's alien some
people call them god other people call
them aliens some people call it
intelligent dimensional being yes
so when you mention jfk saying there's
like a greater force at play we're all
imagining there's like some military
industrial complex but it's actually a
fifth dimensional dmt elf or something
you know a demon from the from beyond
the veil joe rogan would fall out of his
chair
yeah right yeah i it's more fun to
believe in in that stuff yeah more fun
well definitely true spirit war is no
joke were you gonna say well no i was
just i was gonna say absolutely i'm a
big believer you know i'm a person of
faith i believe that a lot of this is
spiritual warfare and it's interesting
to see the people who have realized that
over the past few years i heard tucker
carlson speak of all people and he was
speaking actually at a church that i go
to in san diego and this guy's on stage
tucker carlson largest talk show this
was like three months ago largest talk
show host in the world and this guy
looks at this audience and says i am
thinking i'm insane in real time for
even saying this because i two years ago
never would have believed myself if i
said what i'm about to say everything
that we're seeing is there's something
deeper going on there's something
spiritual i'm not sure what it is but
there's some deeper war at play here
because this doesn't make sense anymore
like all the basic fabrics of a fabric
of humanity is being ripped up things
related to our identity who are men who
are women like basic things that we just
accepted as truth for thousands of years
now people are attacking and so he
basically said i have come to believe
that this is far greater than politics
this is way deeper and so i do think
there's like a cultural shift happening
when we're all realizing that this goes
a lot deeper than just party politics
it's not like a gop versus dem thing
there's a much deeper thing going on
even in the political world there's a
uniparty we clearly understand that now
and that unit party often acts in the um
antithesis of the interests of average
americans and you look at these things
and you're like there's something deeper
happening here that's controlling you
because this isn't
this is so different than anything we've
ever seen before well as a christian i'm
sure you believe that the spiritual
warfare aspect of it isn't new and
that's always been the case throughout
human history but why do you think it's
it seems to be
getting more intense more noticeable
in our daily lives that's i think that's
it it's that it's more blatant it's more
out in the open and there was a time
like an invitation for us to somehow
participate uh my personal belief is yes
my personal belief is that anytime that
you're confronted with evil it's your
duty to stand against it right right so
uh revel is it revelation or revelation
yes revelation yeah revelation
revelation end of days yep and now
what's going on a lot of people have
different views in terms of where we're
at in history i have no idea but i will
say that there is a very clear message
communicated through the scriptures that
as time goes on things will become more
blatant in fact there's a scripture that
talks about how in the last days
everything's going to be uprooted
related to identity people exchange
truth for lies and they'll listen to
things that'll make their ears tickle
and deny reality and so it's like who
knows but that seems like a lot also it
will come in like a thief of in the
night
therefore yeah you really can't know the
day or the hour yeah
both of you are christian
so uh my question i suppose is
um
is it preferable that we are in the end
of days and something is culminating as
to your faith or would it be preferable
that
life was just simple and normal and you
were farming corn with a smile on your
face great question i think you can have
both life is simple and you can have
normalcy but also
uh
not not be excited for the end times but
have hope
you know
and not be so pr prideful as to think
you know what the timing is because i i
think about this in a
like a more secular context but also a
religious context and i'm imagining you
know are there people who are excited
for
revelation for the end of days for the
second coming for the rapture or
whatever might be happening
and if and if if you separate the faith
element from that are there people who
think
in reality we could choose to be happy
live and live in on a farm and have pigs
and chickens and food
but many of these people
would prefer the chaos and the violence
because they believe at the end of that
violence is the utopia yeah the good
news there are a lot of people who
i think at least who
want to make things worse as quickly and
as intensely as possible
so that it culminates in something
and i don't know what that will be
accelerationism yeah but i think you
know the bible's pretty clear about this
like there's the apostle paul that says
that we should pray for peaceful and
quiet lives and yet his also message and
it's not a contradictory one but his
tethered messages and also prepare for
what's coming yes so there's this
tethered reality of like pray for peace
and quiet and do whatever you can to
make that happen
also you need to be prepared yes because
there will be a reality the world is
delving into chaos and you want to be
ready when that comes and so i think
it's that dichotomy a very literal
example that is that every 20 30 40 000
years we get hit by comets and
everything gets wiped to zero and like
that's been happening over the last
hundreds of thousands of years in the
geological records of cometary impact so
like
yeah you want to live in peace and love
your whatever the last
well i know 12 800 years ago at the end
of the younger driest comet shattered
over north america and peppered the
glacial continent melted all the ice and
just caused a global flood wiped out all
the megafauna in north america flattened
the united states which is why they have
these planes yeah maybe that's the great
flood yeah then no it was uh
a couple few thousand years later there
was another flood which they think was
noah's flood like six thousand years ago
that mythology goes across cultures
every culture has like a flood right or
something like that you have a great
flood story
but you are spot on like there are these
things that will come that there's no
ability to control and no matter how
powerful the cabal or multiple cabals
are like even they will be taken off
guard yeah i think when you were asking
that question earlier about why does it
seem like it's all coming to a head
right now the spiritual war i find that
it's always is but now because of the
introduction of psychedelics into the
mainstream the proliferation of the
knowledge through the internet people
are sensing it i can feel it i was like
a logic if i can't see it and prove it i
don't believe it that was me until i was
23 years old now i feel energy i see
patterns because of thc and the
marijuana
psilocybin just when you start to see
the difference between life and non-life
very starkly and and and i mean you
start to practice reiki and things like
that or reiki i'm not sure i pronounce
it is that a good thing i think it's
necessary to understand what's happening
that may be true ian
but i believe i have a story which is
which shows us a sign it is the end of
times
from the ap
ex-ohio court mediator arrested
allegedly sent feces to gop please okay
please explain please don't do this
don't richard richard stein steinle a 77
year old from mogador ohio former
portage county common police court
mediator
charged with sending injurious articles
as
non-mailable violating federal law that
prohibits mailing certain things
including hazardous materials according
to court records
it carries a maximum prison sentence of
one year and a 100 thousand dollar fine
people have lost their minds that's
disgusting now i do think stuff like
this probably happened all the time with
people doing weird stuff there was also
this video of some woman mailing her
period i guess to like the supreme court
right yeah
now here's the funny thing she may have
staged it
because she films a video and then it's
like it jump cuts around and she may be
thinking like i want to actually do it
that's gross but by making that video
which doesn't understand is that you'll
still get charged yeah there were people
when there was a bio weapon well it
doesn't matter if you mailed it if you
show yourself
doing something that implies you did
they have to go and and check every
mailbox and they have to like so uh
search for it there was that story of
the woman
who uh licked the ice cream put it back
yeah and everyone's like but she bought
it right after it's like doesn't matter
did she though no one knows that they
saw a video for looking at putting it
back and now they have to come and throw
all of the ice cream away because it's
contaminated yeah so this guy we got it
we have to throw away the entire gop
they've all been contaminated
that's a white pill you know what i've
heard about poop it's not the poop
that's that's bad for you it's the stuff
that grows on the poop oh gosh yeah i'm
not sure bacteria it all feels bad
future fact i don't want any of it
thrown at me
and cadaverine yeah interesting
molecules you know what is sad though
what did they say the fine is in here
hundred thousand yeah okay what's sad is
like knowing today's modern left that
will be covered in a gofundme oh i'm
sure
speaking of feces i have received
confirmation of the tilapia
um it says tilapia in the wild feed on
algae but on farms they're reared on
corn or soybean meal however when no
other feed is provided they will eat
poop there have been instant instances
where fish farms in asia were found to
be feeding poultry sheep or hog manure
to tilapia oh no wow
cool that apparently is true what is
this gus mcgill university tilapia on
the poop connection
great is that is that what you were
reading yeah
that's so disgusting
very unscrupulous operations apparently
ooh yeah because they have farms around
corn however the no feed is provided
they will eat poop there have been
instances where fish farms in asia were
found to be feeding poultry sheep or hog
manure to tilapia
what
do you guys know about gutter oil oh no
yeah wait why is this vaguely familiar
it was it was like a viral video a long
time ago
they in china they scoop out sewage
and they filter the oils out and then
cook with it oh no on the street
but because they're cooking it does that
mean it's not like infectious anymore
well infectious is it isn't the issue
the issue is like are you eating food
like is the oil mineral oil or like what
oil is it yeah they scoop things out of
like what is it
what is it
yeah like not all oil is food the oil
that people ate before maybe maybe
whether spiritual or not this is like a
sign of the end of days when we're at
the point where we're recycling
manure from animals to feed fish because
we need food to sell
maybe it's like
you know rather than to feed soil we've
gone too far it's time to turn turn back
yep go back to the to the good corn
harvesting yes
come on seiferts
it's our time to shine yeah but you're
what's interesting is that
the pro on this the the beautiful nature
of the times that we're living in is
that people are waking up and in turn
pursuing a lot of things that help them
prepare
for the whatever days that we're in also
help them fight back those that really
feel convicted to stand up like they
have more resources than ever the good
news is is that we're in a time where
i'll give a perfectly um relevant
example to what we're doing on our
platform on public square public sq.com
if you want to check it out there's a
group called front yard farms there's
like a community group where all these
people and it's one of our most popular
groups on the app right now because it's
all these users that are coming in
together that want to learn how to grow
their own food and it's grown by the
thousands in the past few weeks and
that's really neat because what it shows
to me is like okay there's really an
ownership that individuals are taking
over their own existence they are trying
to prepare themselves for whatever is
coming and worst case scenario uh
they'll need it they'll need to learn
how to be completely self-sustaining
because the world will go so crazy in
the united states the american
experiment as we know it today does not
exist in 20 years like
what we're seeing the best case scenario
is now you know how to grow tomatoes in
your backyard and good for you you took
ownership of your own destiny and you
actually provided for your family that's
amazing when you pull the tomato off the
vine and bite into it nothing better oh
cherry tomatoes
we had cherry tomatoes growing every
morning i'd go out i'd get fresh eggs
from the chickens cherry tomatoes and
peppers and that was my breakfast come
on but we learned the hard way we
planted all of our tomatoes at once
too many tomatoes don't do because then
all of a sudden one day we had like 50
tomatoes and we couldn't eat them you're
supposed to plant one wait a week plant
one wait a week
yeah or can them i don't think we're in
the end days that phrase gets comes up
sometimes but for every one of us these
are the final days because this is our
life totally there will always be an end
to our life so every individual can talk
about it as if this is the end because
you only have this but we we mean kind
of like the end of this era yeah you
know because i actually don't think
we're in the end of time either my own
personal views i think we're at the end
of an era that the world has looked a
certain way and it's about to change
yeah i heard engine industrial
revolution i did hear this it may not be
true but um this is the dawning of the
age of aquarius oh yeah 22 30 i think is
when that begins of the age of aquarius
right interesting
let the sun shine in you know we're
going to be tapping the vacuum for
energy dude do you guys know seed
bombing you ever heard of seed bombing
no they retrofit c60 bomber planes
and they pack them with seeds like trees
saplings and they fly over like
deforested areas and just drop hundreds
of millions of seeds they don't plant
nearly as well as doing them by hand but
they can drop
magnitudes more of them and they said
they could plant like a billion trees
per day wow levels of terraforming it's
gonna be funny when in like 30 years
they're like we got to cut trees down
there's just too many there's there's no
more carbon dioxide
for the carbon we need the carbon yeah
dude we're going to be able to mine and
burn carbon and then grow trees remember
on mars remember when they said to uh
not use paper bags because it was bad
for the forest to use plastic when i was
a kid that was the big thing yes
they were like stop using paper bags
they're tearing the forest down use
plastic then like they were like stop
using the plastic bags start using the
paper bags they're getting pollution
everywhere and it's like
it's like for every problem you think
you're solving you're making a new one
well that's a great point because san
diego actually was a national case study
which is where i left san diego um a few
years ago they made plastic bags illegal
formally at the city level in san diego
and what ended up happening is that the
trash that homeless people would leave
on the streets in san diego got
exponentially worse and not just trash
but also like their own human fecal
matter and we try to figure out why like
why on earth is the trash um just so
exponentially greater than it was even
six to nine months ago and they tied it
back to that policy what used to happen
is that homeless people would put their
trash and their feces in these plastic
bags and would throw it away but now you
have the scenario where you took away
their access to plastic bags and so the
alternative is that we have trash and
feces flooding the streets wow and so
you don't realize with foresight how
these decisions are going to impact you
10 years down the road solar panels is
another perfect example you guys have
michael schellenberger on huge fan of
michael read apocalypse never if you
never have fantastic book but michael
talks about this all the time
they when they go and recycle these
solar panels they go and put them in
impoverished communities in africa in
the land and then it pollutes water
supplies like we don't think about how
this the windmills will affect eagle
populations we don't so you think you're
helping something and in turn you're
actually causing a really detrimental
effect yeah i was telling you before
i've been working with this company that
pulls uh carbon dioxide out of the air
and then converts it into graphene and
it the problem that can come out of that
is that we start pulling too much carbon
out of the air and then we start killing
off all the
plant life but thank god i thought of
that now hopefully you know we'll be
able to mediate and make sure that that
that isn't a problem that is created
from the mining
uh i think it was funny we mentioned the
other day
when the wind turbine started leaking
oil yeah and then everyone was like huh
what do you mean yeah it's like they
they thought they don't do that yeah
yeah they need oil they gotta lubricate
them yeah and not just to maintain them
but to produce them in the first place
this is this is this is the challenge
with um
i don't i don't know how you solve our
political issues we have a great
government i mean not literally today i
mean a system of government was devised
by the founding fathers which is quite
brilliant but has devolved into some
kind of nightmare
and what happens is you get a politician
who's like
doing stuff is hard
saying things is easy that's right and
so they're like we gotta we gotta have
green you know green is better than
brown or or or or gray or whatever the
cities are supposed to look like they
want the green initiatives not the
machine initiatives
and then
what ends up happening is they say we're
gonna we're gonna build wind turbines
and everyone says that sounds good and
then it costs more to do the return is
is is insufficient and then people think
they're doing better but they're just
spending money cars is a good example
one theory going on right now is that
the big push for electric vehicles is
simply because they're trying to save
the auto industry a huge portion of the
us economy is based on cars people don't
buy cars anymore there's too many
there's so many cars and they're getting
better and better and they last longer
and people drive less like what do you
do
electric vehicles now we're going to get
rid of all the gas ones and go all
electric
that's convenient because it helps uh
keep the the gas for
you know machinery and things like that
that you know more industrial use cases
but i think i think it's likely a big
component is just
make electric cars because now all every
everybody's buying up all the electric
cars and they're hard to come by and
there's huge demand
economics
not environmentalism
so maybe the end of days
maybe
maybe
let's
well i was just going to say one more
thing on that the i think part of you
asked a question in that and the
question was how do we fix the system
when the system is so broken in what
seems like an irreparably
um
almost like you just can't even there's
no point in even trying and my my big
message to people all the time is go
local first start at the local level
like i can't change my country until i
change my state i can't change my state
until i change my county i can't change
my county until i change my city it all
starts in my backyard like if we can
actually stand up for the needs of a
local community and get that down and
get that unlocked okay then we can start
to focus on our state that's like what
public square is the app that you built
it's like
what is it like it's like craigslist but
but more like um
more vetted yeah so it's essentially we
started a platform to help connect
freedom-loving americans with the
community and companies that share their
values so we've been really disheartened
by what corporatism a big part of our
system being broken is that mega
corporations have gone kind of into the
progressive authoritarian world and
partner with big government in this
effort to kind of stamp out the small
business world and also the values that
still tens of millions of americans hold
dear like individual liberties freedom
prosperity and this has been evolving
over the course of the last few years
and then covet blew it up because you
had businesses all of a sudden literally
bar you from employment or even
patronizing their place of business
unless you agreed with their set of
values related to certain medical
choices and so we started this app that
basically helps people take local
communities back through the power of
localized commerce and so it's a social
marketplace where users can connect for
free with all the businesses that have
agreed to a set of values to basically
say we're going to stand for the rights
and principles that have made our
country special in the first place then
they get discounts for going there yeah
and a lot of these businesses so you
mentioned the seven principles yes those
are those sounded great yeah so when a
business comes on it's free for the
business to join um right now we've got
about a hundred new businesses that are
joining every single day and they're
loving the experience because it's a
great advertising source for them for
free so we don't charge businesses we
don't charge users we make our money
through advertising um that we don't
have to sell user data for which is a
big point in fact if you go to our home
page you'll see a transparency page at
the bottom of this so if you scroll all
the way down you'll see a little
transparency link at the bottom
this actually has our core values then
it also if you scroll down even farther
has the kind of tenants of our platform
that you know that you can trust as a
user and as a business
but when a business signs up they agree
with seven values that are essentially
at a high level we believe the
constitution is worth protecting we
believe in the rights of every
individual in the public square
especially related to health things so
no massacre vaccine mandates if a
business is on this app it means that
they will respect your personal choices
in that world these businesses don't
donate to any intersectional politics
meaning they're not going to yelp has a
big problem yelp last year came out and
gave free advertising to black owned
businesses wow at the expense of
everyone else isn't that of like illegal
it's yeah 1964 violation of the civil
act like civil rights
would that be title seven i believe
racial discrimination yeah sure yeah
yeah especially as it relates to even
employment i mean that's happening in a
big way right now so um a business
that's on the platform is not going to
identify themselves by their skin color
they're going to identify themselves by
the quality of the products that they
produce for their consumers bringing
this back to
supporting the free market of small
businesses to be able to operate with as
little government intervention as
possible which is big in a state like
california where it's impossible to
start a small business people people
need to share this public sq.com because
if you know we often talk about don't
give your money to people who hate you
you know jeremy's raisers have that
funny line stop giving money to peop
money to people that hate you give it to
me instead yeah but
but transparent
but how do you find
more people like yeah you know jeremy
boring or the daily wire yeah uh like
this yeah so if you live in an air and
you're like i don't know what to do well
here's one way to look up and if if at
the end of the day you are avoiding woke
businesses and only going to people who
you know share your values then you are
shifting a massive portion of the
economy and power
into
better values you're spot on and and
like this shirt it's a great example i'm
wearing a shirt called rowan for
rowan.com it's amazing they didn't pay
me to say this they're not even a paid
advertiser but for rowan.com they're on
the app with a free profile this shirt
they
source their products sustainably
they're an amazing company run by a guy
that holds these values to his core
convictions um
it's it's his it's his worldview to a t
one percent of all the proceeds that
they make off of their clothing go to
fatherhood so there's this national
fatherhood initiative that helps to
provide father figures for communities
where kids didn't have them it's like
these are the companies that i want to
support with my dollars not things that
are donating to blm with their corporate
profits and what's neat is that you know
we have 15 000 businesses on the
platform with the largest network of
these patriotic businesses in the
country and um the largest industries
are restaurants retail clothing and
droids small businesses that make our
country special because not only is
there like a yeah let's be anti-woke but
there's also like let's just support
small businesses in general because
they've been so hosed by what's happened
over the past few years the fact that
amazon gained in value over the last two
years while small businesses are now in
a situation where 70 percent of them in
the united states may not be able to
stay open after this fall because of how
hard they've been hit like that to me is
one of the greatest crimes against
humanity i've ever witnessed and so
we're trying to support not only the
businesses that share our core
convictions so that we're not funding
companies that hate us we're also trying
to help just small business in general
because there's a need for it now today
more than ever what what about a company
that's in a jurisdiction that mandates
things like if uh these businesses stand
against it in fact we've paid the legal
fees of businesses so they'll they'll
reject they're like yep unconstitutional
you're from chicago originally yeah
nene's deli great deli highly recommend
if you're in the chicago area um they're
one of our promoted partners they're
amazing on the app and they stood
against the mandates in chicago which
was nearly impossible they refused they
said the rights of our consumers are too
important we're not going to infringe
upon them and they got fined but we put
together a group that went and paid off
their legal funds and said keep fighting
the fight don't back down you'd mention
that you want to open uh source the code
at some point what's your timetable for
that great question uh
the desire would be in the next 12
months um but it's it's really hit or
miss it it relies upon a few features
getting done and us getting more
algorithmic based where there's anything
that you'd want to be able to use in
different environments so um that's a
great question like i could see like an
airbnb all the people that are airbnb
their house is also using an app like
this but not your app because it would
set up it would create new live maybe
new nut liabilities for you uh if you
get into those markets um but that if
someone else spun up like a like a
public square
v2 or like uh you know whatever you want
to call it with that code and then you'd
have like a b and you'd have like a
like would you do you have rentals like
airbnb on there yeah we have housing
rentals so a lot of people have said hey
i wasn't a huge fan of how airbnb came
out and contributed dollars to
employees getting abortions across state
lines because that was a big initiative
that airbnb pulled about two weeks ago
and so we had a lot of rentals on the on
the app that said hey we're here don't
forget about us we're not with airbnb
come join us and we'll gladly rent your
house so there's um absolutely there's
an incredible market for also like local
bartering so people that have just a
single product that they're trying to
sell at a local region that's great for
them too if you're in an area that's
super rural and there's not a ton of
traffic we just launched this nationwide
six weeks ago so word word word enjoyed
it and diving right in
but it's been amazing the response thus
far one of the greatest
challenges is how do you how do you make
this critical mass enough for people in
hyper local communities that are way out
in the middle of nowhere part of the way
that we do that is also offering an
online marketplace you can also shop
your values in the online setting and
can spend money with the businesses
there that are agreeing with these seven
values but they'll serve you wherever
you're at in the country and so but
you're right in terms of how this can
have cross-functional applicability into
other environments the sky's the limit
um is it the kind of thing where i can
order like food from the restaurant
through your app not yet you'll be able
to absolutely yeah essentially it's a
directory at the moment um with a social
component but it will absolutely i mean
you should see where we're going this
fall we're starting to get more into
e-commerce you can actually purchase
right there and have it shipped to your
house from within the app itself right
now we essentially act as a directory to
get you to the businesses where then you
conduct and your shopping experience and
a lot of these companies will give you a
discount code for shopping there that's
the neat thing too is that me as a free
user i get a free cup of coffee every
week from a public square coffee shop so
it's really neat i just i just signed up
and i'm looking at the local area and
there's a ton of stuff oh awesome i just
signed up i went there's a barbecue
place in uh well i won't say the city
but there's a barbecue place near here
oh cool run by great people highly
recommend check it out what's the name
of it do you have the name of it uh i'll
say after the show yeah i don't know if
you guys are because it's about where
you shout out it's very close to you
there's a lot of businesses in it really
in the local in in local that's great
check online because there's
that's great news because we're in a
pretty rural area so when i when i when
i look on the map yep and it shows all
the little spaces yep the pins all those
businesses have agreed with us that's
amazing they've come through is there
ride sharing uh not yet but that's
something we're super excited about yeah
we can't wait to it because it's super
easy to do the technology's there um
yeah ride sharing is big bartering is
huge for us um a lot of these like
moving into the craigslist the angie's
world or angie's list market becomes
more of a reality in the near future
we're excited about what's coming what's
angie's list he dogs barbecue yes
charlestown oh is that the place you
were talking about yes yeah they're on
there yeah there's another cafe that's
there i went to today pretty cool well i
i i gotta understand this is my country
where yeah
yeah
jesse would agree yeah but you guys
would know about chicago
i mean the reality is the job board do
you want this to compete with linkedin
or something like that great question
yeah so that came about really as a sort
of a fluke we had a lot of businesses
during around the time that um the
vaccine mandates were coming out we had
a lot of businesses like hey i'm hiring
and i won't infringe upon people's
rights can you just put that somewhere
and we've had a lot of people get hired
through it and we've got an amazing
partner in the job board space called
red balloon that's helping do kind of
what we're doing but in the um in the
jobs market more more exclusively that's
really exciting andrew their ceo is a
good friend of mine and so we're
partnering together in a lot of our
technology so two things here first of
all i remember i tried to download um
your app earlier before it was rolled
out yeah i was very disappointed that it
was available everywhere uh i'm very
glad it's available now the other thing
is that red balloon i looked at and they
appeared to be defunct which was very
disheartening so do you know if they're
expanding as well they are definitely
expanding okay yeah cool yeah and then
what is the biggest like uh roadblock
you foresee for your company it's a
great question uh the biggest roadblock
is just we to be honest we've got um a
lean budget and a lot of interest which
is great news like it's great that we're
the largest entity in this space and
praise god we've had a lot of success
thus far and that's solely because these
businesses have taken a stand and we're
grateful for it
but like that also creates a lot of
challenges because now we're building
the plane in flight and so anytime
you're building the plane in flight
there are just challenges with the
things staying together and holding fast
but if you go to like a city like
chicago you'll be amazed at the amount
of businesses we have a thousand
businesses in chicago like tim if you're
up there and you search that current
location bar
um
no x out there um go back okay hit the
current location bar see the current
location right above you oh a little red
bar what i'm not going to press that
okay oh no no that won't show your
current location oh it's going to be a
search bar let's see if this is one of
the things you're changing oh okay yeah
if you uh if you uh
uh if you go to that current location
bar and you search you don't have to do
it now but if you search chicago there
instead of your current location i just
want to show you an example of like a
largely blue city that has just blown up
chicago atlanta um phoenix san francisco
has done pretty well new york city is
awesome great yeah if you scroll over to
chicago oh hey detroit what's up hey
yeah if you scroll over to chicago and
then you hit search this area
just so you can see like what a city
looks like when it really blows up i'm
gonna go check out my neighborhood i
love chicago here um let's see how we're
looking so scroll up
okay now hit search this area let's see
that's great oh my gosh look at that and
these are just local ones so these don't
count all the online that serve us this
area this is so cool yeah it's really
neat it seems like a great way to help
people feel like they're not alone
that's the whole goal are you looking
for investment at this stage uh so we've
taken just angel investment um we're
staying away from all venture stuff
just it robs you of a lot this is
amazing thanks dude so i'm i'm in my old
neighborhood where are you at oh you're
right by midway and so the fact that you
can find businesses that share your
values in a place as blue and insane as
the south side of chicago yeah is that
it really indicates that the blue and
red is kind of a visage it is people are
people
i mean we love our bro if i like i'm
going to use this and go to these
businesses you should 100 i don't want
to give money to people who hate me amen
that's why we exist yeah and the deeper
emotional connection is i feel not alone
like we had it'll almost make me tear up
when i talk about it we had a lady reach
out we'd only been launched a month and
she said i feel we soft launched in san
diego and she reached out and she said i
feel like i have 6 000 new best friends
in my neighborhood like that was really
really cool because it was like it's
it's amazing to be able to shop your
values stop spending money from
companies that hate you go for all of
your life's purchases and feel good
about your purchases it's a whole nother
thing when you can feel like i'm not
alone anymore when i that's why when i
look at an area in the south burbs of
chicago and you see a cluster you know
these people are all friends they told
each other like they absolutely are yeah
they're probably getting customers
and part of the way we grow is through
an ambassador program so like we have an
amazing chicago ambassador and so the
chicago ambassador goes out refers all
these businesses to the platform
recommends them to the platform it's
really neat and so that's um that's part
of the way we grow it's very grass roots
we have a team of activists around the
country literally a parallel economy
that's the whole so great how do you vet
the companies like if someone did do vax
mandates how would you get that so we've
had two instances since we launched um
at all even including our soft launch
back last october um we had two
instances where a user reached out and
was like hey i think this business may
have been with you at a time but no
longer is they just let us know and we
kept moving on so we pulled them off
okay off we go yeah we're committed to
the rights of our consumers though and
so if if a business is on there and they
got to be with us and it's not it's not
a tribalistic thing it's just that
there's there's a constitution in place
for a reason we want these businesses to
respect that and um and consumers
deserve to know that i'm not gonna go i
remember how embarrassing it was like
covet i walked into a coffee shop and
got told to leave right away because i
wasn't wearing a mask like that's
embarrassing there are a lot of people
in there the last thing we'd ever want
to have happen is a consumer feels that
way and so
that's why we really do hold fast to
these values so how do you kind of how
do you kind of not enforce but encourage
people to adhere to these rules because
you're right these are great principles
but how do you make sure that they're
following through even like one year two
years five years for sure great question
we ask for consumer feedback on every
interaction that's a really helpful way
so if a user shop somewhere we asked
them to let us know how their experience
was um and you know again 99.99 of those
interactions are incredibly positive we
learned new stories through it um
but it's it's everything too it's random
industries uh like we had an
office supplier from alabama joined last
week he heard me on this tv show and um
he said hey i just want to let you know
he called me because i hadn't talked to
him in eight years but i know this guy
personally he didn't know what i was
doing now he calls me and said i just
want to let you know within 24 hours of
being on the platform i had an office in
ohio call me for supplies from alabama
and they're my new client oh my god
they're one of our largest clients so
it's really neat to see like even the
way businesses are now supporting
businesses and that's cool like the b2b
side of this is limitless too so we're
excited to get into that a little bit
more you said earlier
ad revenue is how you make the company
makes money right now but you don't
track any data
we don't sell any user data and any data
we track is purely analytical and it's
not based to a user so it's basically uh
we can tell a business you got 8 000
impressions this month but we can't tell
you demographics who did it right the
gender any of that we don't even ask
users that i guess it wouldn't be
untargeted ads the ads are targeted
people that like the business of they're
targeted to the entire platform like we
don't have any ability to target other
than your region so we can tell you
chicago you get an ad that runs in
chicago but we can't tell you to what
demographics or what but if someone like
browses a lot of restaurants do they get
restaurant ads no not yet no and even
when that comes in it'll be user
preference driven it won't be a hidden
algorithm so
what'll happen in the near future in
the beauty of building the plane in
flight what will happen in the near
future is that when a user signs on
they'll actually tell us what they're
most interested in so i really like
restaurants i really like coffee shops i
really like companies i really like
graphene
and then and then what will happen is
that what you'll see will be most
catered to what you told us but you can
change that at any time other categories
can i say like show me restaurants yeah
yeah yeah oh wow yeah so if you scroll
down i'm totally doing this like
tomorrow forget something so if you
scroll down um
uh you'll you'll see categories so you
get another category so that's in
chicago in that region if you go to shop
online you'll see like there's uh
a whole list of categories if you scroll
down um you'll see all these yeah
yeah if you want jewelry if you want
clothing you want retail you want tech
services you have made it very easy to
stop giving money to people who hate us
that is music to my ears that's great
news i'm very glad to hear it's not just
about not giving money people hate you
about giving money to people who who
like you yes yeah and big time that is
what it's about and it's impressive you
did it with a small team thank you like
you said you it was just a couple a
couple of you started it off yeah we're
now we're now at about 24 people on our
head count that's impressive thank you
thank you it's been a lot but it's been
incredible that's in like a year was
that a year you went from yeah we wrote
our first line of code 13 months ago
that's so neat wow did you just get
struck with the idea yeah it we needed
it you know i have a lot of respect for
business owners that start
entrepreneurial ventures because they
see a hole in the market there's a whole
other level of fulfillment when it's
something you personally have felt and
my wife and i we
we felt the covet thing hard i mean we
just felt so disheartened by what was
happening we made a list of all the
businesses in our local region on a
piece of paper that we knew we could
support because we knew the owners we
knew they would stand with us um so it
came out of a lot of personal
experiences the desire to feel connected
to people and not alone
because you can feel that way especially
in california and so what about
businesses that might be services with
no physical location right yep yep those
are on there too plumbers electricians
financial advisors
we got it all would that pop up on the
map or what are they uh they'll pop up
on the map if they have at least like a
focal point that they like to service
um but then they'll also pop up in the
category list without maybe necessarily
a physical pin on the map if they have a
surface area but no physical location uh
yeah it's really neat wow that's so is
there like a woke version of this they
have that don't be yelp yeah
all of them yeah everything next door
yeah
yeah all of them yeah wow but you're
right though it is it is for us like we
get ass all the time why won't you
create this big blacklist and tell me
all the companies i should hate and it's
like because that's that's evident
that's out there like we'd much rather
focus on the positive here's where you
should go like it does mean no good to
tell you
i mean it does you some good knowledge
is power but like you know chase and
bank of america don't like you what i
would rather do is tell you about access
which is like an incredible freedom
loving bank that holds fast to the
constitution and they'll serve you
anywhere around the country access bank
axos
check them out they're amazing axos
they're based out of san diego x os
clothing companies like for rowan i'd
rather tell you about this because it's
hopeful it gives you hope in the country
i'm not a big fan of the don't give
money to people that hate you because
they i don't think they hate you they
just don't care about you i'd rather
complete individual money to people that
like you yes and support your ideals yep
exactly that's why we exist i'd rather
give more money to somebody you know
serving food
who was cool and was nice and supported
what i supported as opposed to literally
anybody else what ian said i think there
are a lot of business owners who
if they knew your political leanings
would like kick you out of their
businesses there are ideologues out
there and when i walk into a business
that has like blm flags and
like the newest updated lgbt flags
everywhere
all over the walls more than their own
branding i
do think that it's meant to deter
anyone who's not woke from entering the
business and supporting it
yeah that might be something in that
yeah and on our vacation it was terribly
sad because i had somebody say to us if
i had known that you weren't vaccinated
i wouldn't have invited you and i was
like crushed that was like crazy
sad it's horrible they're locked in
weird mind statement and that's what tim
talks about the cult and i wanted to say
in october of last year we were talking
to this big crowd of people we had at
our little event i was like you know
what you guys should feel like great
about this because this
tells you that you're not alone like
this is something really impactful and i
feel like this app is the perfect
representation of that that's so
exciting yeah thank you that means a lot
yeah
what we do i love it do you have venues
on here like oh yeah we have a really
cool art collective venue that just
joined from san diego highly recommend i
can't even remember their name but if
you look in venues and cities we have a
music venue in indiana that just joined
like really cool
yeah it's awesome yeah because that was
a big thing during covet there was a big
vaccination push for music venues and
some bands required it not even because
of their personal convictions but
because the venue required it and so we
wanted to kind of counteract that as
well those venues also need to let uh
some comedians know who's allowed yeah
yeah
big time we're gonna go to super chats
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it and become a member at
timcast.com we're gonna have that
members only show coming up for you at
11 p.m but let's read
i'm gonna have to keep this one short
from eric just read the beginning he
says tim you're right about the civil
war and he says he helps people prepare
for what's coming
um i have to tell people just
preparation is
being sustainable
figuring out what you need to survive
and not relying on a machine or a system
because you don't know what's going to
happen that's all i can really say i
don't know what else preparation would
would really mean because no one knows
what will happen we may be in an era of
purely fifth generational warfare it's
all psychological operations and that's
it but we may end up seeing something
like supply chain disruption so
preparation just literally means do you
know where your dinner is coming from
download on your phones
a survival guide
not because the world is ending but
because some days you might find
yourself lost in the woods yeah that's
it you might want to learn how to start
a fire or something if you're gonna have
a campfire with your friends might not
have coverage i just got notified that
the app public square might actually be
overloaded right now uh people aren't
able to sign in they get to the phone
number part and then it kicks them back
yep they can skip the phone number part
if you'd like to there's a skip for now
that can sometimes help i figured that
this would probably be a large traffic
spike if we give it a minute
yes all devs are on alert
we've got an amazing team i wish i knew
about the sooner legit when we go out on
the weekends and stuff i'm only using
these businesses
it was so i i got to say it was awesome
to go to chicago and look at my
neighborhood and see their businesses
there and it's like
very few you know surprisingly i mean
there's a lot there you can see on the
map totally but not as many as you'd
hoped for i mean but it's chicago what
do you expect well and we just launched
i mean the you know again we've only
been nationwide for six weeks so part of
that is like it's it's such um once once
communities find out about it and then
the businesses start telling their
friends like that's what's led to
blossoming growth it's so great yeah i i
had uh um
i had friends who worked at places uh
that got fake ratings on yelp and things
like that dude i knew a guy who ran a
burger joint and he said that he would
get these fake reviews on yelp and then
all of the good reviews would be held as
spam and all the bad reviews would rise
and then you get a phone call being like
hey why don't you advertise with us and
he'd be like no and then it would get
worse
like we can give you special editing
access i don't know if that's true i
just know that's what a guy told me to
be kidding it's real that's crazy and
they'll help some businesses alleviate
bad reviews and they won't others based
upon their political views that's shady
yeah so like a lot of the businesses
that have taken stances for anything
remotely right of center
if they get a negative review from
someone in new york that's clearly never
been to their business in phoenix yelp
won't help you even if you're a paying
client you have to pay a lot to yelp to
really be shown anywhere like in any
serious degree like starting at 300
bucks and yelp's an expensive platform
for an advertiser and so you have these
advertisers that feel part of the
community and yet they get completely
slapped in the face i feel like you
should ever have to have a receipt in
order to leave a review i think that's a
good idea that's a great idea yeah you
can scan it all right or or maybe
if the the receipt can go through the
app you know what you should you know
what you should do ready i'm all ideas
payment build a plane with us payment
processor
so when people integrate that so you
know you go to the store and they have
the thing the tablet and they spin it
around and you tap and then you slide it
back the receipt stays within the app
boom there you go man love it all right
celine hope says i think a two-year
mandatory military service would solve a
lot of america's problems it would
correct bad parenting lack of discipline
and addiction
i don't disagree but i also agree that
it would create a ton of new problems
and i'm not sure i would agree with
conscription yeah i like the idea of
people getting discipline i don't know
if i like the idea of
how i don't i put this i don't think it
can be implemented what about military
school
people should have to serve two years of
military school
i don't know i i mean i wish that i'd
learned military tactics at the age of
17. you know i love military tactics and
i don't know why but i love them they're
interesting well then the question
becomes who is teaching those tactics
and it would probably be the state if
you're going to give it to the military
well and if the military is teaching
the military schools what they're
teaching the military currently no good
i would not let my kids go
yeah
triton54 says tomorrow's headline a.g
merrick garland orders the arrest of
conservative protesters outside judge
reinhardt's home oh boy yeah except for
the ones screaming to go do some crazy
stuff no they're basically the point is
they wouldn't do it to the supreme court
justices uh they wouldn't arrest people
outside their homes right
yeah
all
right
augusto
mimochet says
the house select committee on
assassinations concluded that jfk was a
conspiracy and the next day all the
evidence used in the committee was
stolen from cia storage that's
crazy or not you'll look that up someone
just
i don't know interesting if true it was
definitely a conspiracy we just don't
know who conspired
all right
alex maguire says
i only know that dan bongino is the guy
that posts that biden is the worst
president in u.s history every day on
twitter maybe you can have him on irl
i'm already a subscriber to tim cass but
maybe people should know him uh he's a
cool dude people do know him he's cool
he's huge yeah he's actually helpful too
what's that bon gina's been really
helpful to us he's promoted us a lot in
the last month very grateful for i have
to say i used to think he was crazy and
i do not anymore did you hear his his
rant
last night on the news after this broke
about the fbi ranking trump's place what
do you say he uh called it some third
world bs and just went off about how our
country is a banana republic i mean yeah
you have the current president's son
that's doing what he's doing and yet the
opposition leader is being raided it's
like that's the most clear evident form
of banana republics that you can
possibly dream about i look that up yeah
damn was going off
all right let's uh let's grab some super
chats
david c cronk senior says do you think
it's possible that the dnc knew this was
in the works so they funded candidates
believing the raid would hurt them
maybe 40 jess yeah the idea is to make
trump look like he's culpable or
something's going on
yeah
i don't know man i guess i just find it
hard like i think this is firing up the
base even further i don't know who that
person was on twitter today that had the
viral tweet where he's basically like i
was on the fence about trump 2024 but if
this turns out to not lead to anything
and this is a witch hunt like i'm all in
he's got my vote i think they're gonna
be a lot of people that are like that
solely because they are so frustrated at
the establishment pulling yet another
example of this tyranny
all right let's grab some super chits
bobcat says don't forget a president has
unilateral authority to save something
isn't classified anymore a secretary of
state does not so even if he had some
red stickers the law says he can
is that true
trump can just say it's not classified i
don't know i think we talked about that
was it before the show oh yeah
like if you want to be like oh all the
kennedy stuff d-class all the alien
stuff d-class all the secret weapons the
cia's that d-cl no i mean i can't
imagine that would fly that it may not
fly because there are other powers at
play but i think it is legal yeah i
think you as a president can basically
declassify anything you want because
you're the commander-in-chief you have
the sole authority over issues of
national security and classification and
so and what's interesting is if you dig
back even deeper the last kind of
modification to that classification
um rules and parameters was made by
obama in 2009
who basically made it way more lenient
and vague so um very interesting but
all right thorin park says ian's shirt
looks like it's made out of children's
party napkins
yeah that's awesome is that that plastic
tablecloth that you start tearing apart
because you feel anxious i think it
would melt on a hot day yeah definitely
someone gave this to me i love it aaron
freeman says lest we not forget they
wanted garland as a supreme court judge
they're going for broke now how do we
stop activist shenanigans this election
you got to go and tell literally every
single person you know about
true every single one of them also
fortify your life so that shenanigans
aren't going to destroy it you know make
a make a system that can withhold that
kind of stuff because that kind of stuff
is always going to play out you go you
call everyone in your phone book and say
hey you going to vote you go knock on
every single door hey you going to vote
and uh you get 10.
every person gets 10 of their friends
and asks them are you going to go vote
and go vote
oh this is important purposeful porpa
says trump had element 115 in his safe
the zeta reticulans will not stand for
this i was like bob lazar
yeah is that what he said yeah zeta
reticuli i think when bob was working at
area 51 um that they told him that there
was a zeta reticuli there were little
green men and there was a special
element 115. so it's like a red herring
so if bob ever went rogue that he would
look like an idiot because there is no
zeta reticuli there's no element 115. if
there is it's not what they were using
they put a puppet of an alien up in that
drone that they were working on and made
him think it was alien
wild
tavnazian
one of trump's attorneys says they are
not in possession of the warrant
presented by the fbi prior to the search
at mar-a-lago they were allowed to see
it then it was taken away
that sounds strange
i don't know about that yeah
all right
my zu yang says what if biden and his
party want trump's idea of how to make
america great so they are stealing his
documents by raiding
oh yeah that's what it is they want to
make america great trump's going to win
so they're going to steal his plan
[Laughter]
all right
jimmy joe says crystal knocked was
november 9th shortly after the reichstag
fire
interesting
christopher lambert someone check ian's
dice no one rolls that many twenties in
a row naturally
it's this one right here i don't know if
you can see from here someone yeah
it's all twenties so that's the one he's
rolling oh i saw someone in chat i'm not
saying that there is no element 115
there is but what they told bob at that
time they had not developed 115 yet and
they just gave him some random
futuristic element that would be
realized in the future now we have it
keith fraser says don't forget the jfk
threatened to break the fbi into a
million pieces is that true
i think it is yes yeah he did yeah i
don't know if those are exact words but
yeah he said he was going to shatter it
into oblivion
wow it's a metaphor well it wasn't that
wasn't the i mean the conspiracy around
it like the week before he had premiered
some sort of something that was going to
lead to the shattering of some of these
three agencies that's a big thing that
always you know joe rogan's big on the
timeline of events leading up to the
assassination and how was that jfk
revisited documentary that was really
good two years ago but i'll talk about
this too yeah talked about kind of the
timeline leading up to it and uh yeah
apparently that's the story is that he
not only said that but there was some
actions in practice and splinter the cia
into a thousand pieces was the actual
quote scat and scatter it to the winds
yeah as a cia
let's see h music says hillary didn't
learn when she made her love trump's
hate campaign slogan it's only missing
the apostrophe so now she's trying but
her email instead do you guys remember
that i remember the first time i saw the
signs love trump's hate and i was like
she wants me to love trump yeah i
remember because he used hate or
something like i don't i don't
understand like you're saying trump is
hateful and i should love his
hatefulness love that and then someone
explained to me what oh
because the t was capitalized i didn't
understand
i get what wow these people are terrible
i thought i'd check that a good meme
would be love trumps
just like get it like when you trump
something it means you're like beating
it you're like one-upping it that's what
love trumps that's it yeah
well yeah i take that to me and it's
like do i love the trumps is that what
i'm supposed to i don't know yeah i'm
confused
they tried to meme yeah andrew ryan says
a man chooses a slave obeys
true
brian david says i am also left-handed
with a recent left-hand injury
also my membership was automatically
renewed via paypal two days ago oh no
was that not supposed to happen or
were we supposed to use parallel economy
if people are signed up through paypal
paypal is just going to do their thing
until they switch
but uh we're we're
there's i can't say too much but we're
working on new infrastructure stuff so
i don't know
yeah
um but if you do want to support the
show we use parallel economy so when you
sign up for timcast.com you're not only
supporting us you're supporting parallel
economy which is a censorship resistant
financial transaction service and our
infrastructure is built on rumble so we
we very much are trying to
help flourish and grow this
this ecosystem so that we can get away
from the super from the
from the super chat
says ian check out the global
consciousness project i know that
global sounds interesting alex remains
he says rudy giuliani on crowder's show
today said i try to show today that the
fbi were the ones who put
locks on the door where the docks were
allegedly being stored
interesting is that
really i don't know i don't know what
that means they locked the door or
something
no idea
grafty says buck the peck button buck
buck buck yeah graffiti a big fan of
chicken city yes we love grafty chicken
city uh a few of the chickens have moved
uh to a new location top secret location
they've been rehomed
yeah the chicken city is much too large
there is too much chicken poop it smells
wow it does and especially on a warm
humid night
through my closed window
big city
jacob carter says as a christian i must
say one the rapture is non-biblical
nonsense two i can't wait for the second
coming but understand it's up to the
father also hope you're having a great
day guys god bless
would you would you agree with that
agree i would agree on both counts
all right
ken says i keep alluding to moving out
to provincial philippines it's my
graphene
these same new york times libs complain
about the government then celebrate
worse
uh
i can't read that i don't know what it
says uh never coming back to the u.s
well all right if you feel it like i
feel graphene follow your dreams
zebba zepeda says dude you should pay
attention to south america communism is
brewing down here in chile look for the
4th of september
and uh what does it say boric
he has all of the dictator vives
oh and in chile that happens with salmon
oh no the chicken poop stuff fish
not the poop fish no i thought it was
only the tilapia oh sorry don't ruin
salmon for me as well don't let me have
sandwiches
of living in san diego lots of fresh
fish yeah i lived in santiago chile for
a while and what i noticed most
notoriously was that all the police in
in the city were national police they
were like feds there is no local law
enforcement there so if a crazy guy
takes hold of the cu that government he
has the entire country's law enforcement
system wow e rodriguez says tim i live
in new york and i am completely fed up
with modern leftism and while i hate
staying moving to a red state at this
point in my life is extremely difficult
but i'm not giving up on it i hear you
man yeah um it's not easy for everybody
when i was in chicago and i moved to la
i just took a backpack and a cup on our
bucks and just went no plan nowhere to
sleep just whatever figured it out
worked out
i don't know though suppose if you live
in the middle of nowhere you're going to
be sleeping outside yeah
i guess sleeping outside is better than
sleeping outside sleeping outside in the
forest or a field is better than inside
the city very true i don't know a lot of
bugs come to california yeah
trying to make our state seem better
we're trying to not only move in there
[Laughter]
all right waffle sense it says ian have
you ever thought that you're not just
seeing patterns in the universe but that
you're feeling god speak to you because
in my experience god manifests this kind
of way not with some audible voice in
your ear yes waffle sensei i love you by
the way man um yeah uh god speaks to me
in shapes i see visions of behavior i
don't necessarily sometimes i'll hear
words like an impulse of a sound but
normally it's a vision of me doing
something or something happening when i
ask a question that's the response
the bible for unbearable says revelation
18 23 for your merchants were the great
men of the earth and by the sword by thy
sorceries all nations were deceived the
word sorceries is translated from the
greek word
yeah pharmacao ah that's right wow
really weird yeah
interesting the spirit of sorcery that
takes over the world was the spirit of
pharmakeia
very very interesting yep revelation 18.
i've there's been for for a while now
people have been talking about the signs
and they they're they're trying to look
at revelation and then say like look
this is this thing and this is this
thing totally but i've heard that for a
for a while you know people thought
hitler was the antichrist because he
talked about establishing the third
reich which was literally going to be
like a thousand-year dominion right
people you know there were a lot of
reasons that christians have thought we
were in the final days for literally
thousands of years so yeah i missed the
pharmacao what was that uh revelations
18. you can read the exact verse again i
don't uh 1823 yeah look up look at
revelation 18 23. yeah mr toad says what
is public square's version of esg
oh i love this question
uh yeah we adamantly stand against esg
environmental social governance
standards if you're not familiar it's
the new philosophy that's overtaken
especially the world of corporate
investing and so most any company you
buy from that's owned by a corporation
at this point
adopts these esg standards and they rob
your life in a lot of ways they
basically prioritize woke politics and
near-sighted and uh uh
almost ignorant
principles related to the environment in
their production of goods that you buy
and then they make you come along that
journey with them and they also carry
that into hiring and so this relates to
things like diversity quotas dei is
another word that's very similar
different philosophical framework but
they go in tandem often which is
diversity equity inclusion public square
uh stands against it by not focusing on
identity politics at all and the thing
we are more most concerned about in the
world of manufacturing is not carbon
emissions uh it is make your stuff in
america because if you make your stuff
in america statistically it'll lead to
less emissions because china is the
world's great polluter right now and
most of that comes from manufacturing so
if we can trust that you're making your
products in america there's a good
likelihood that it's far more
sustainable than what's happening
overseas too right waffles says have you
guys seen saudi arabia's the line it's a
mega city they are building look it up
it's weird dystopian stuff
i i have seen so many videos like this
it's nonsense some artists probably made
it i don't think what's happening in
this agenda 2030 concept is mega cities
that they want to put humans in like
centralized spots so that they can have
far like wild land but the problem is
humans centralized do not do well we
need to be able to move in different
directions to get away if there's a
disaster not just that
if you take
a little bit of chicken poop let's say
let's say one mop bucket full and throw
it into a field give or take how long
until that is washed away and dissipates
rather quickly i mean one rain probably
take i don't know 200 tons of chicken
poop and centralize at the same place
and how long until it gets washed away
exponentially longer when you put all
these people
in one city and they're all taking dumps
every day
how do you how do you wash that away
it's it's very very difficult to to
maintain and manage that system could
have to hit with lasers whereas for
people live in rural areas where on
septic systems know that
if you do it right you can leave that
system for years you have to worry about
it you know too much because bacteria
takes care of it that's right that's
called sustainable living yeah i was
just picturing a septic tank with a
laser inside that blasts the carbon and
turns it into graphene once it hits
remember the flooding in the new york
subway system that was happening
and people were talking about how that
that system it was built so long ago
they think it's on its last legs but
there's nothing you can really do to
repair it
yup so in new york i could be wrong
about this this is what i was told you
got these big nitrogen tanks on street
corners you've seen them before probably
big chrome tanks of nitrogen and you'll
see like steam you'll see like a big
orange cone of like like steam coming
out
what i was told is that
the wiring systems of new york are so
old that they're melting underground and
falling apart so they blast nitrogen to
get to exhaust the heat
so it's like a duct tape solution to the
problem yeah maybe it's not true though
i mean just some dude in new york told
me that so maybe it's not not real but
you gotta understand when you build a
machine like the subway system
yeah repairing that
is difficult
like what do you do it's like okay we're
we're advancing our new technology but
we've got
how many square miles
how many how many how many miles in
general of track
that you would need to change for new
technology
that's the challenge of these big cities
so one thing you'll see is fascinating
cell technology in poorer countries
would be better
than they were in america the united
states we get the like i think the first
networks like the iden network
and so you know we launched the cell
network and we're like look at this our
phones work in other places poor country
couldn't afford it so they didn't build
it
then the technology started becoming
cheaper and cheaper but by then we had
already developed cdma or something like
that so then these poor countries
implement the stronger better technology
because it took them longer to get wow
and then we're trapped with these old
garbage networks that we're trying to
repurpose looks like new york's got 248
miles of routes uh this is subway the
subway system 665 miles of revenue track
i'm not sure what that is exactly but a
total of 850 miles of track wow so
there's revenue and non-revenue track
i'm not sure no that's crazy
do you guys know much about starlink
i have starlink you do yeah do you like
it uh we we've done tests on it and the
upload rate is impractical for a
business
yeah five yeah your last point
impractical for a streaming business
yeah i mean for any business to be
honest gotcha so they're still in the
early stages yeah yeah yeah we we got
the i got the i got the rv version and
the business version yep and the
business one's much bigger and it's not
faster have you had luck linking them
together we have not yet bonded them
uh but that um that's the next
experiment we need to do because we have
three we have two rv units and one
business unit
and so we also have the ethernet system
and we have a bonding unit
we can actually
separ spread them out
blast them all off and then bond them
and then it's a diminishing return
five megabits up per each you'll
probably end up with you know 11 or 12
megabits
gotcha so it's a diminishing return not
bad yeah not bad but um
you know it's good i mean it's for
people in rural areas starling is
fantastic yeah well in those poor
countries like you're mentioning if
you're in a poor rural country but i'll
be honest if you're running a business
we already have satellite internet
that's that's good yeah i think our
satellite internet is actually faster
than starlink but the latency is 10
times slower
that's the issue wow with starlink the
latency i think was 68 milliseconds and
our existing satellite uh is like 360 or
something like that so so five times
it's faster but it has worse latency
what's that mean exactly it's it's
longer ping
so if you're playing a video game you'll
get lag
right you're playing world of warcraft
craft you're gonna switch
more data per packet but it sends
packets less frequently it's a further
distance because uh uh starlink is low i
think it's low or low low orbit yeah i
got it out
yeah
i think that's what it is i don't know
the lower latency allows you to send and
receive signals faster but there's less
data in it i guess it could just be
because of congestion or something you
know i have no idea
we'll have to get elon on the show and
ask him about it yeah that's a great
idea any time any time
jos mosk says
2 timothy 3 1-5 talks about the last
days before the return of jesus and
sounds like where we are now in the
world
okay but i think it also does i mean you
mentioned like hitler because hitler is
the best example of someone that would
have been the antichrist i can think of
yeah yeah yeah there's a lot of reasons
as you look back in fact there's a year
maybe one of y'all can help me and look
this up but there was a year i think it
was 9 36 a.d 6 30 6 80
it was the darkest year in human history
because the volcano blew up in southeast
asia and it sent the whole world into
black for a year like the sun didn't
shine for a year wow yeah and crazy it's
like you hear stories like that you're
like can you imagine what the people
must have been thinking like they had
no and yeah diseases start running
rampant like you had every reason to
think you're in the end times wow and
here we are today so you know
stellar orbit says i think we crashed
the public square app yep yeah yeah
it'll be back up we've got an amazing
team of devs this is the the beauty of
building the plane in flight and we just
launched so i really appreciate the
traffic that's amazing but you asked the
greatest challenge which is in the world
of software uh when you've got a lean
and mean team accommodating the demand
thank you so much everybody for wanting
to join the community it should be up
and running back to you asap bro
finbrofin says mike is there an api
uh lots of apis uh for it would depend
on what they're looking for oh well in
terms of like being able to source
businesses from the platform for other
uses uh yeah kind of yeah
all right
kyle bratton says literally literally
just downloaded the app we'll be putting
my business on here and convince my
friends to do the same hey that's
awesome that's what makes the platform
special that's so cool i was surprised
how many in dc were on the app right
there's a lot yeah that's great i'm
going to dc this weekend we're going to
make sure we're going to go into good
businesses
who don't hate us yes absolutely and i
would probably i would probably assume
too
because while there are a lot of
businesses
i wouldn't say it's a large percentage
of total businesses right like 30
million small businesses in the united
states yeah and so we've we've got
awesome partners in the space that have
had a lot of hope for us from the
beginning because they just have been
exposed to so many small business owners
you guys have had charlie kirk on your
show yeah charlie kirk when he first
heard about this in january looked me in
the eyes and said in the next year
you'll have a hundred thousand
businesses on this thing i mean the the
market is just so large for it because
there is such a coalition of these
people um so yeah the potential is
pretty wild 30 million small business
united states and what gets me really
excited is like all the employees that
are positively affected through that
because you think for every small
business you've got a few employees most
of the time you're accounting for too
and so um if we can help even a tiny
percentage of that like that's a dream
come true a lot of people are asking
about canada
ah yes we are okay
we're coming i'll tell you that and i
will also say this it is our next
country
so
let us uh take care of the united states
first and
bit more uh 30
robust team and then we will take on
canada but that is our next stop all
right one more super chat we got justin
greene says joe kent wins primary
election joe kent won i don't know i'd
have to check i believe it the eight day
election or whatever yeah yeah all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and head over to
timcast.com we're going to have that
members only show coming up for you at
about 11 p.m tonight you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at timcast mike do you want to shout
anything anything out considering we
just shouted out publicly yeah
i feel super grateful public sq.com if
you want to learn more about the site uh
you can follow me on twitter at real
michael seif s-e-i-f just half my last
name i'll make it easier on you at real
michael seif that's where i'm out on
twitter that's probably where i post the
most and we'd love to have you on the
journey with us right on if you want to
see me more often you should go follow
me on instagram or wechat at closerkitty
and you should go subscribe to pop
culture crisis on youtube we go live at
3 p.m eastern noon pacific time every
monday through friday i'm getting
confirmation that jamie herrera butler
conceded to joe kent
that's from fox news great news right
guys great show tonight awesome to see
you mike that was great really cool
actually really awesome uh bye everyone
i love you yeah and i would say two for
this app crashing tonight to check in
tomorrow thank you so much for coming
discussing this with us michael this is
a huge
white pill i'm so glad it's working now
and i want to say there's an old latin
adage with set which says we're all
familiar with it if you would have peace
prepare for war and i think that's the
best way to live life and i will leave
you with that you guys can follow me on
twitter minds.com at sourpatchlids as
well as
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you